the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the first St Louis super
twist I'm feeding Master Doug Eckert and
I'm here with
here with your dad very excited to
be doing commentary for this
Awesome event in San Luis yeah this is
the first whisk that we've ever
broadcast here from St Louis and we're
looking forward to this we've got some
very strong players and some very you
know very good young up-and-coming
players that should lead to some very
exciting chess
let's look at some notable players that
are taking part in the competition here
are some of the names
first player Grandmaster Gregory o'parin
who's recently switched Federation ends
representing the US
then we have Grandmaster Ilya niznik
well
followed by Doris reardz vastiff
durarbali Aram hakobian
Grandmaster Lazaro brazon
yester quesada
VAR akobian Christopher you
Brandon Jacobson Robbie kevlashvili
Balaji dagobati and elshon moradia all
of these awesome Grandmasters are going
to compete
for
six
so the tournament format that we're
going to have is a nine round Swiss
event there are two rounds a day there
is one time control it's game in 90
minutes plus a 30 second increment for
move one this format generally leads to
very exciting games because the players
have a relatively limited amount of time
to think and they're not getting a
second time control so as they approach
the end of the game they'll often be
playing on a 30-second increment
all right so we'll go on with the
schedule of this tournament
uh for round one we're starting to the
round actually already started there's
going to the games are going to be
broadcasted with some delay so uh today
March 12th will they will have round one
at 11 A.M followed by 5 PM and each day
the rounds will be
starting at 11 A.M and then 5 p.m so
that's going to be March 13 March 14
March 15. the last round is going to
take place on March 16th at 11 A.M so
we'll be uh broadcasting all of these
games live will bring you commentary
from the tournament and hopefully some
interviews with the players on site
um we're really looking forward
to those
and if your guys are watching us
we hope that you know you come say hi
and let us know your thoughts if you
have specific questions you can follow
us both on YouTube or on Twitch so
welcome everyone if you're joining us
from either one of those platforms
all right so let's check out the
pairings because we already the round
one has started and we already have the
pairings Doug would you like to
so on board one we have Grand Master
ilian niznik versus International Master
Hosea Stearman and Hosea made his first
Grand Master Norm in the last week or
two so he's a player on the rise
Josiah I apologize
um on board two we have international
Master Irene sukhandar versus Grand
Master Darius swears
and board three baseifter Bali versus
International Master Evan Park on board
four we have FM Alice Lee who's one of
the young up and coming female players
in the U.S versus Grand Master of ram
Jacobian
on board five we have Grand Master
Lazaro brazon versus fide Master Aaron
Jacobson
and some very interesting matchups there
with some young players coming up that
are playing against extremely strong
Grand Masters and that's right and I
think it's very important to mention
that we'll have we have about 50 players
that are taking part in the event we'll
have about 10 games broadcasted live but
there will be other games as well
um in the tournament of course because
there are so many players so we haven't
received the games just yet they're they
haven't
um
the broadcast doesn't seem to be up yet
but hopefully we will get
to see it coming up soon I know we have
about either 15 minutes or 30 minute
delay for 30 30 minute delay I'm told
um but it's going to be really exciting
I I noticed a lot of very strong female
chess players are taking part in the
tournament there might not be
possibility for Norms but it's
definitely one of the strongest
tournaments held here in San Luis the
Swiss tournaments
organized by the club and
um
as
yeah I think we should maybe go over the
price fund what do you say that's yeah
that's exciting and it's the first
tournament that we actually do
commentary for so uh both Doug and I are
very excited to be the first hosts
co-host of of this tournament right yeah
so this first super Swiss here in St
Louis so the price phones up on the
screen at 6 000 for first four thousand
per second three thousand third two
thousand fourth fifteen hundred for
fifth a thousand for sixth and then you
know as the prizes go down they're
paying through 20 places
um there was no entry fee for the
players here so this is a a good
opportunity for a lot of players to to
make a little bit of money and for some
of the younger players to get some good
experience against some of the strong
Grand Masters that they'll be facing and
we're hoping to get to the games up on
the board shortly here we keep seeing
there's a little bit of a delay in the
broadcast here and right now our screen
is showing there's still a five minute
delay coming up and we're trying to get
that gangsters were talking here
and and someone asked whether we could
get the entirety of the player list up
on the screen
um we're looking into that to see if we
can get the whole list up there's 40
four players in total on our list and
you know from what I can see there's
actually only 20 boards paired right now
and there's one half Point by so I see
41 players and we'll see if we can get
that up on the screen here shortly yeah
I think
um our team is still working on on
putting together that there were some
additional players who have joined the
tournament I think last minute so we'll
definitely have that ready by tomorrow
for sure
um I I think we didn't mention this but
I think it's important to mention that
we will be doing commentary for the
event for the morning grounds so we'll
always be here around 11 30 a.m central
time we might go on a little bit earlier
and we'll go until the end of the rounds
um and um and the rounds will still be
broadcasted and you will be able to to
check the games live online but but we
will be commenting typically the morning
runs and maybe who knows next uh next
day so tomorrow maybe we'll we'll be
able to check some of the previous games
as we're waiting for for the new ones in
case
all right so it seems like we'll be
getting the broadcast shortly
um
okay but until then were there any
interesting questions in the chat that
we could take
um we want to say once again hi to
everyone who's joining us from twitch or
YouTube thanks for being here
um
oh it looks like there's an ALICE Lee
fan club someone's rooting for Alice now
this has had a brilliant
she has had a brilliant um
tournament I think right
um yeah she's been playing very strong
recently I I played in a norm event with
her a few weeks ago and I believe she
started out 5-0 or 6-0 in that event and
she did make her Norm she was playing
extremely well throughout that event
she's very tactically alert she's very
well prepared she's a difficult out for
anyone at this point and she's only 13
right and she's only 13. she she just
said I think she has her birthday
recently and and she's had some really
great tournaments she's also playing in
the protest league for the Archbishop
art what's this she was playing for the
St Louis Archbishop team
yeah she's she was basically a star I
believe I saw in an interview Fabiano
was mentioning that he believes she
could be
definitely becoming a Grandmaster very
soon he sees a great future for her so
Fabiano caruana that is yeah and
someone's asking whether the broadcast
will cover the evening rounds where
we're not planning on doing that as we
sit here we're planning on covering the
morning rounds which would be rounds one
three five seven and nine in this
tournament that's correct and we saw
previously on the screen a picture of
Alice very much focused once again there
she is I remember actually played her in
US championship last year in 2022 and I
had a tough time
um eventually our game ended in a draw I
didn't have a very good tournament she
had a great tournament however and I I'm
looking forward to seeing
um future her future in chess
were there any other questions while
we're waiting someone asked about the
prize fund again I mean I think we can
try and put that graphic back up on the
board it's a total of 25
000 with 6 000 for first and
um you know it's a nice prize fund for
for this group of players like I said
there's no entry fee for this tournament
it's an attempt to bring some strong
players together and
um it should be a great competition just
because of the mixed rating within the
field and you know a lot of the lower
rated players are also young and up and
coming players that are going to put up
great fights against these high rated
players so it should be a great event
yes hopefully we will be able to get the
games
um I think everyone is looking uh oh we
got the games yes that's sure that's
come up on the board we'll just come up
on the board
very exciting all right so I'm putting
the first board up
um do you have a preference which which
board to start or why don't we go on
order of the boards here we'll just go
through the top you know 10 boards and
take a look at how the games are
progressing all right so let's start
from the beginning so we have
Grandmaster Ilya nishnik playing against
josephia sermon actually I did play
Josiah a few years back before he was an
international master and uh I I don't
remember if I wonder Drew that's bad I
sure remember my my results but I
definitely did not lose uh when when you
see a kid that's up and coming it's uh
it's always
um you always want to do well because
you never know when you might get the
chance to score some you know some some
points with them
um so it looks like we have an English
uh and then transposed to a nimsa
Queensland Queens Indian
B6 G3 this is very much Theory Bishop A6
Queen A4
are you familiar are you
playing this yourself I I don't play
this particular line I I know B3 is the
heavily analyzed main line and queen A4
has been around for 40 years yes
um I've seen I've seen B3 quite often in
this position I don't know if
I've seen people going Knight D2 here or
not I don't know if it was here yeah
Knight D2 is also a move here it's not
extremely popular because it doesn't put
pressure on D5 in this position
and in these Pawn structures
um you know the ability to play C takes
D5 and have e takes D5 as a forced
response is a very important theme for
for white
that's right and then whenever the
bishop will end up going back in B7 the
bishop will be restricted uh by the pawn
that's quite quite a typical thing that
white ends up doing so I sometimes like
to play 92 but typically against Bishop
B4 check so this is this is another line
Queen A4 Bishop
usually has to go back to B7 so that the
Knight can develop Bishop G2 and this is
still
Theory I believe yeah absolutely it's
Theory I mean this type of position
often leads to Hedgehog type Pawn
structures
um it's not a structure that I play very
often in my games but it certainly leads
to very tense positions with both sides
having chances
I agree I used to play the nimzo I
actually one of my most famous games was
but it was not Queens Indiana it was
nimsovich actually I call it names of
which people tell me Sabina stop doing
that in Romanian in Romania when we
learned when we learned to you know when
I learned to play chess we call it the
names of nimsovich or just nimsa you
know and but a lot of people think of
nimsovich as another
opening so sometimes I end up still
saying it wrong so I apologize in
advance if you will hear me say
nimsovich to this which is the Queen's
Indian I know but anyways um so this is
this is just still early in the game
we're going to see
um
more
later as to how the game continues shall
we go to yeah
so we have international Master Irene
sukhandar from Indonesia
against Dr Schwartz he was a member of
the U.S team in the world
Team Championship in 2019 I believe
um so okay what did we have
E5 all right
uh are you playing these kinds of
Sicilians at all with black so I in
addition to being an over-the-board feed
a master I'm also an international
Master at correspondence chess normally
I am a D4 player as white but in
correspondence chess I often open E4 and
I actually played this line in a game in
the last year is white I often thought
of this as an inferior opening for black
but in fact I didn't really find any
advantage for white whatsoever which
surprised me
and now what Darius has done here is
you'll see in a move or two is he's
played G6 which is a move I'm not
familiar with so he's obviously trying
to mix this game up against what he
perceives to be a lower rated player but
I'd never seen the move G6 in this
position
I see it I'm not familiar with the
Scholastica at all like I
um
I know typically in the night or if you
develop the bishop in E7 so as you say
this G6 sounds seems a little bit not
the typical way to go for black since
you kind of have to defend that pawn so
it doesn't seem to make sense right to
develop it on the other side or since we
play A6 we don't care about that pawn
very much right I mean typically in this
type of position you know White's gonna
put the Knight on B1 on C3 the dyno B5
is going to be driven back to A3 and
then you'll go to Knight c293 and then
have a knight on D5 and black would
typically want to be able to put the
bishop on f8 on G5 to trade the Knight
when it hits E3 in these positions and
when you commit with G6 you've taken
that option away
and Darius is a very well prepared
player so I can't imagine he played
something like this without having spent
some time analyzing it but
it's
something I just haven't seen before
well me neither but I guess we'll we'll
learn it's always nice to do commentary
I find because oftentimes
um you might not have the ability to
um to check every single game every
single new idea that's uh that's coming
up that becomes topical and I think
being a commentator you'll you often
learn new things and
um yeah so hopefully maybe
yeah it's a very very interesting idea
and we'll see how the game progresses
um looks like they made two more moves
so A6 as you said similar to a knight of
or uh yeah Knight E3 and then yes that's
going to be something that we want to do
I think compared to those it is nice
that white already has the pawn in C4
because typically you don't have the
potency for you kind of black already
has B5 right so they would play it on a
different move order like can I actually
make the moves
like this right yes here here Knight F6
Knight C3
um A6 no oh no I wanted to show that oh
E5 okay E5 here
right this line
no am I wrong am I am I confusing that I
confuse something I confused something I
can see I confuse something yeah I think
right after which C3 you would play I
would have said yeah
oh so it's E5 first then right I'm sorry
it's not with G6 so it's um after what
line do I wanna I think you want to show
Knight C6 uh Knight C6 D4 right okay I'm
sorry E5 no Knight F6 Knight C3 and then
um E5 okay like this here here
but then you have to play D6 right and
then it's Bishop G5 A6 here this is the
line that I wanted to show B5
Knight here
Bishop E7 C3
or takes Bishop takes F6 right and then
C3 right so I know there's some lines
where white actually plays E4 in these
types of positions yes
um but it usually takes takes some time
and of course black will put the bishop
in G5 and then say there are some ideas
with G3 H4 the bishop goes to H6 anyways
lots of theory that has to be studied
for people for both white and black if
you're going to play this line but what
uh what darish played he allowed Irene
to get the pawn to C4 and in a way it
could be a plus I'm singing but of
course I don't play this line so
I could be totally wrong I guess we'll
we'll have to wait and see someone in
the chat suggesting Bishop A6 is a
possibility as a substitute for Bishop
G5 and and it might be we'll just have
to see how the game develops
um and of course you also have to be
careful you know when you move the
Knight on G8 either F6 or E7 that that
Bishop's not protected on H6 so that
could lead to some tactical issues in
some lines but as the game progresses
we'll see you know how Darius intends to
deal with his bad Bishop in this
position I agree
he's going to be a little bit tricky I
wonder if he um he's thinking that white
would take when the bishop is played in
age 64 it would take and then maybe he
could get the Knight back into Placer F7
if we push that pawn and then the Knight
could be the protector of D6 in some way
yeah and that's an interesting plan
because the Knight on F7 in these types
of positions you know performs a very
nice role there it makes it very hard
for white to get to the D6 Pawn
and my experience in my correspondence
game in these types of positions is the
computer will show that white is you
know marginally better you know plus 0.3
or plus 0.4 but then trying to turn that
into something concrete
um if it's well played it's black it's
probably not possible I
okay well we'll have to to wait I didn't
turn the engine on yet maybe we will
later to see what what it says but um
yeah I am anticipating some nights you
too
um in this position for for white and
then uh we'll have to wait and see if
if Bishop H6 is
um or was darius's idea or or not oops I
think
right all right we're good we're good
okay oh was it played no it wasn't
played that was my move okay moving on
to next game yes all right board four
grand master versus Bailey against Evan
Park
um
what did we have a real Lopez
Bishop B5 do you are you familiar with
any of the players yes
um I I know the thief very well he went
to Webster University here in St Louis
and I understand he um has been playing
in the US or may have even recently
moved back to the U.S but he's someone I
would consider a friend Evan's a young
up and coming player and I I don't know
him as well
all right well A6 Bishop of course I
know vasift I know vasif I heard about
Evan
um I think he was I might have seen him
some tournament
um okay
so Bishop E7 I'm actually playing this
line with black myself B5 Bishop B3 D6
all theories so far H3 okay
so just the closed the closer Lopez and
what system did he choose to go
all right so far is still theories I
think the players
might end up play Fast actually it's
surprising that black is still thinking
in this position typically I think this
is this is the next move that has to be
done like
here Bishop f8 you're you're and then
and then you have to get your knight I
don't know if if in this system you're
getting your knight to D7 or not
this was the other way that you're going
to attack the center in 95 or 98.
right yeah I mean this system was made
very famous in the karpov Kasparov
matches
um from the mid-1980s where I thought
the theory was Bishop f8 Bishop C2 e
takes C takes and then Knight B4
um which leads to some very sharp lines
after Bishop B1 and C5
and this was played you know I don't
know half dozen times in the karpov
Kasparov matches and the Theory's gotten
very deep here
um and you know there's lots of
sacrificial attacks after D5 and then
black has one of a couple moves here I
think he can play either C4 or he can
play for Knight D7 and F5
so he's gonna he's gonna give up he's
gonna give up the pawn like just get 93
and then allow
this Pawn is eventually going to be lost
right it will eventually be lost and I'm
not sure what I but I think you have oh
I can't do that Queen B3 then right
so Queen B3 and
how is black going to get his Pawn back
he's trying to take advantage of this
but then I'm protected I guess it will
take some time it's not so easy for
white to probably
if white would get maybe to capture the
pawn and maybe go B4 Bishop B2
that could be something
yeah I I'd have to think about this for
a minute here because
um it's been a while since I've looked
at these lines but I this is an
interesting this is an interesting line
that you suggested I don't think I've
seen it played like that yeah you know I
I when it happens I think it's after
white plays A4 before you play Knight B4
so let's go back I probably messed this
up here
so maybe not Bishop maybe A4 here
and then going into that line but then
it's after they played Bishop C2 so I'm
trying to think what other I think black
throws in H6 at some point so maybe it's
H6 here and then after A4 by white we
take then you take take and then play
night before and then you get this
position with C5 so my apologies there
no no all good all good and then after
C5 D5 then black has a choice of either
playing you know Knight D7 and F5 which
is very very dangerous because you're
exposing the black king or you know
playing for C4 and it does ultimately
involve a pawn sacrifice where Black's
gonna you know play Knight D7 Knight C5
and put a knight on D3 while white is
making progress on the king side
something like that The Rook can come
over at least a fascinating positions
um
and again I I probably make an error
here because I know there's certainly
positions after F5 where this has been
analyzed very deeply and um you know
black can get instantly checkmated or
White can start losing all his pawns and
end up losing the game so it's a very
interesting system and
um you have to be very well prepared to
enter this through either white or black
I started liking it as soon as you
showed that idea so I feel like this
could be something I could I could look
into myself
um did we was there any other
um looks like a zaitsev yes it does look
like a
like a zaitsev yeah I think I believe
it's called the zait surf system if I'm
not mistaken there comment on the
comment here is probably correct
but I'm surprised that black didn't go
for Bishop fa because that's the next
move after you go Rook E8 this is this
is the next move that should be played
in my opinion quite instantaneously
um that's that's the reason why we're
doing that I also know that sometimes
you go G6 Bishop G7 I know you're
mentioning maybe H6 but I I have played
this with um with going with G6 and
bringing my Bishop so that I have this
Pawn protected I typically don't like to
take here too soon personally but in
some lines you kind of have to otherwise
you're going to struggle if if they play
D5 I've played the often that you go in
with with Knight A5 but obviously not
here earlier yeah I don't think that the
line I suggested after A4 and E takes D4
for black is forced it's the most active
but the plan Sabine is suggesting here
with G6 is also very solid for black
it's less active yeah and I've played
the brayer line which is related yes
yeah and the problem with the brayer is
is it's very passive you often end up
with your pieces they look very nice for
black but it's hard to be active and in
today's chess the players are active
with their pieces and those types of
openings are less popular mm-hmm
that's right and I've seen some
questions coming in the chat someone was
asking us if we're doing commentary for
all the rounds if you joined in a little
bit later we wanted to let you know once
again that we will be doing commentary
for the morning rounds so the rounds
typically I mean the rounds start at 11
A.M central time but there's a delay of
30 minutes for the games to show up on
our broadcast so we will be starting
around 11 20 maybe or so
um
central time so we'll be doing the
commentary for the odd number for the
odd rounds and I will not be here the
last couple days I don't know travel to
play in a similar tournament to this
towards the end of the week and I I also
yeah and I'm also hosting one of the
players that's playing in the Americas
cup at my house so I'm trying to balance
you know helping with the commentating
and being a host of one of the players
coming into town I see okay so uh you
got some interesting things going ahead
I guess I'll have to find out more
information about that in the break
uh all good but anyways I will be here I
will be here all around so oh well the
morning round so
um I hope you will be joining me
sometimes to maybe we'll go over and let
you guys know about the uh what happened
in the evening rounds but typically
during the morning rounds like we said
who knows maybe that'll be a surprise
afternoon uh stream but I don't think so
if I mention that uh someone in the you
know in the back is probably gonna be
unhappy so I better stop there
um and then there was another question I
think that I saw
um
um someone was asking about the uh the
pair not the parents the list where
where they could watch the pairings I
don't know if we have a comment for that
or if it's going to be added it should
be added on the website shortly
okay
all right so you guys can see a link to
the games in the YouTube description I'm
told
and you can search for the tournament uh
on leeches it's Saint Louis super Swiss
um so hopefully you guys have no problem
finding the tournament mobot might even
give you a link to the event if you're
on Twitch okay move to board four let's
do that we have shown you a picture of
Alice a little bit earlier and now we
get to see her playing with the white
pieces against Grandmaster around
hakobian
so she started D4 Knight F6 c46 I think
this is something she typically plays so
we have again a queen's Indiana Oh no D5
never mind no Queen's Indian so we're
transposing into some qgd
ibd7 Queen C2
Bishop B4
okay
some kind of strange this is not ragos
right it's a queen's gamut Decline and
Alice had generally played Bishop F4 or
move five I'm from someone who had to
prepare for an internment recently and
she started to vary her repertoire some
so Queen C2 is not a normal move in the
Queen's Gambit decline in this position
it's a sub variation
I I can't say that I know a lot about it
and it looks like Haram has tried to
transpose into a nimso sub-variation
but it wouldn't be really ragozan
because the Knight is here typically
it could go there if you check so it's
it's interesting actually you could put
the queen in situ sometimes in in the
world no in the Queen's Gambit as well
two if you play The Exchange variation
and then you go but but then the Knight
would be here and you would go the line
with with uh 92 right correct and
normally you've also defined where the
bishop on C1 is in those variations
whereas here the bishop on C1 is not
defined in terms of where it's going to
go not yet
and it's interesting you know as we flip
through the next couple moves here after
she exchanged and then essentially tried
to transpose into a queen's gamut
declined exchange or maybe the bishop on
B4 is misplaced
well is it though maybe maybe black will
have some ideas if he manages to escape
with the queen from this pin maybe he
will have some kind of um
um
what opening am I thinking of with C6
Queen A5
um Cambridge Springs the Cambridge
Springs could that could that happen
it's similar yeah to The Exchange
Cambridge Springs except normally in
those lines
um
black has played Queen A5 immediately
and then on C takes D5 he's able to
capture with the Knight on D5 that's
true that is true they do that sometimes
yeah
okay so well no Cambridge Springs
something interesting do you think G5 is
going to be oh he played this okay I was
about to say do you think you would play
G5 I would play it
I would go for this line
um it's good it's it's a sharp line I
think 90 night uh E4 you have to go
Knight D2 I think in this position I
don't know if Rook C1
is an option
yeah Knight D2 challenging the night
looks like the right idea to me you know
as an older you know player who grew up
with the classics these types of
positions are hard to wrap your hands
around in today's world you know with
everything being very concrete it's the
type of position that either works for
black or it doesn't it's very loosening
and it's very committal that's right
that's right but white is under pressure
I mean black in these types of positions
can often play C5 to get you know the
queen out and then sometimes the D4
Point becomes soft but at the same time
you know Black's very loose
um you know we'll see here that black
lopped off the bishop on G3 to avoid
Bishop E5 ever becoming problematic
yeah once you commit with moves like G5
you have to do something you cannot just
sit and wait because your king is in the
center and
um you have weakened a lot of dark
squares your Bishop is on this other
side of the board so
um I think this move uh asks black a
question what are you going to do with
the Knight now you know there's pressure
on the night there's pressure on D5 I'm
not pinned anymore what are you going to
do right absolutely with the Knight on
D2 I mean white can often you know play
E4 and Castle long and bring the Rooks
to the Central files immediately so
black has to be very concrete or the
position can come open and you know
black can get in trouble very quickly I
guess this would be another option but
the reason I didn't want to show it
earlier is because if someone is
watching this the stream whether on
YouTube on Twitch they might know that I
have the tendency to give up my Bishop
pair way too soon so I didn't want to
say it but I will say it uh I'll let
that I'll let that pass
um but the point would just be that this
Knight doesn't have pressure here
anymore and typically you do end up
making that move in in a nimsa or
uh but but the bishop is of course here
so you have to be careful sometimes for
for things happening but you always have
the option to take it back so it's not
like we're actually giving up the bishop
pair we're getting it back the next move
so you have to see if you want to make
that trade this is the moment if you're
going to try to say no I will just
capture your Bishop here and then I will
keep my Bishop pair uh because now I
think if a capture were to happen I
think white has this option too I'm not
sure if Pawn takes a stuck
I mean obviously Pawn takes is still a
thing but I would maybe take with the
queen I could be wrong maybe solve it
upon
anyways yeah I I mean I would be a
little bit doubtful about giving up the
bishop in this particular position for
black because it strengthens the D4 pawn
and white really wants to force E4
through here I agree and so I think if
you add stability to the D4 Pawn for
white it makes E4 a stronger move I
agree I agree so I guess anyways he
would she she would be capturing back
with the with the B Pawn in case this
were to happen so anyways that's not I'm
over considering I was thinking C6 here
to protect D5 but it seems like
um Aram went for Knight to B6 directly
so he's trying to open up his Bishop
sooner and not make a decision about
this Pawn just yet maybe he's going to
end up castling alongside
um so that's why he doesn't touch that
pawn just yet yeah I mean there are some
variations in the regosan where black
plays Bishop E6 and queen E7 and then
castles long and you know it retains the
option of putting the bishop back on D6
to retain the bishop pair in this
position and and black is a little bit
passive here compared to white but the
bishop pair here I think is a long-term
advantage in these types of positions
and typically what white would try and
do in this type of position if blacks in
a castle queen size to play A4 A5 to
disturb the Knight but there's a lot of
options and so it's a tricky position to
play because white has to be flexible in
terms of not over committing I agree and
and black at the same time has created
lots of weaknesses so it has to be very
precise here right and I think in this
type of tournament it's very fascinating
compared to say some of the very top
tier tournaments as you have higher
rated players here playing a somewhat
risky opening against a lower rated
player that's creating this imbalance
that leads to exciting chess that's
right that's right and I was listening
to your idea with a4a5 which I like very
much but then I you you might have seen
me highlighting The King and I was about
to ask you what would you do would you
Castle short or would you keep the king
in the center because it's really tricky
here I would be scared to to Castle
short because I think black is going to
be a little bit faster than white
attacking on the king side than white on
the I could be wrong well and that's why
I say you have to be a little bit
flexible here in your outlook I mean I
think white wants to play E3 in Bishop
to D3
and then you have to see how black sets
their pieces up I mean if it looks like
they're going to Castle queenside I mean
maybe you can go right away for A4 and
it's not that easy for black to sort of
seal the queen side with A5 because you
have Knight A2 hitting the bishop
uh I mean it's a very interesting
position
um I I have played the ragozan before
with you know success and you know utter
failure and these positions are very
hard to play for both sides they're very
strategic and one you know air and
judgment strategically as you know
Sabine is alluding to here could lead to
a disaster because you Castle directly
into a mating attack
so I played some similar Pawn structure
notes a hundred percent
um but there is this line with Bishop G5
Knight F3 Bishop G5 against the king's
Indian and I remember years back it
wasn't a US Championship my opponent
actually had the pawn in D6 obviously
these pawns these um the C4 pawn and the
E7 Pawn were still on the board and my
opponent went for this H6 G5 idea just
you know and she won my Bishop the same
way
um and my position was pretty good I
ended up uh just being able to
um to attack this H6 Pawn which turned
out to be weak she ended up casting long
um and then at all these light squares
that were
weak were left Weak by the push of the
pawns turned out to be in my favor so I
was comfortable with that position
um but but here I I think it's
definitely you need to give it a lot of
thought as you you said because it's not
so clear for either sides what they will
do and they still have a few waiting
moves where they can
not decide where their kings are going
to go like you said for white E3 Bishop
D3 and wait and see what black is going
to do
I'm anticipating either Bishop here or
Bishop G4 might be a place to to put the
bishop that way you might not be able to
cast along and then if you play F3 I
might be happy because these pawns will
be weak you don't have the dark Square
Bishop anymore so E4 might not be
something you want to play too soon
right I mean white could also put the
bishop on E2 to control the H5 Square
longer but eventually if black is going
to Castle long white either has to
Castle queenside himself or herself in
this case in this position
well lots of moves were played I did not
do anything okay sorry well we're going
to see real quickly how so so Alice went
straight for a Sharp line and went Queen
side and she's going to open up the
position immediately she's not she's
going for it four times she's she's
going for it she's like you know I
learned that there's a king in the
center and I'm going to take advantage
of that
um that's that's the that's the really
great approach but what is she gonna do
about these phones she doesn't care she
doesn't care she she doesn't go in for
it she she's playing maybe question Roy
style or something no her opponent is
scorching my style grabbing the pawns
but what is going on here this position
seems
um to be going in a different direction
than we thought can't they play Bishop
here right now oh no maybe there's a
wait there's a threat there's a Czech
Bishop threat here black has to be
careful
I almost missed that it's so easy to
miss this yes and for the audience we're
not looking at the engine here and in
these tactical positions that we we can
certainly look not very smart here uh
we're trying in the opening here to
explain these games from a strategic
perspective but this positions very
quickly went from strategic to
um tactical so we have to start being
sharp it's still morning here uh not
that morning anymore so it should be
sharp enough I did some tactics this
morning so hopefully you know I won't be
blundering uh too many pieces anytime
soon but okay we need to come up with
some kind of defense for black
um
I know this no it's not going to be a
good idea
it's going to be
it's going to be a crazy idea like
really crazy idea
what do we think is this a totally crazy
idea probably right
um because because you cannot take at
least at First Sight because of Bishop
F5 but maybe you can do this right well
you if Bishop F5 you're saying I can't
play Bishop to D3 do you have do you
have a mate am I going to get
yeah maybe this is bad
I was trying to be funny but I wasn't
um
of course when you don't know what to do
first thing you should do is give up the
bishop for the night check yeah capture
check maybe you can go here you know it
is always important to look at well but
if I take if you take I want to check
check so I'm thinking that would be fine
for me but I wonder if you can play you
know in this kind of sacrificial style
and just
now and then after Bishop E3 I can grab
your bishop and the Queens come off and
we have opposite colors here
no no no no no no if I move the king
over okay I have Bishop to E3 here as
black maybe
bishop takes D3 and I'm not pinning you
anymore either but I am a mate threat
it's um
it's a very interesting position I
thought I would just go a little bit
crazy and I don't I don't know that this
is a move if this is actually a move
that's good I will be amazed by myself I
usually don't don't suggest
crazy moves like this where you keep the
king in the center
you know what other idea I have now that
I was thinking so I do want to keep the
king somewhat in the center but maybe
not maybe I could it's looking too bad
now
what if I I just
is this I mean
I definitely well you may not need the
castle I mean black could put the bishop
on D6 you know to stop the D5 Pawn
solidify C7 and sort of leave the option
open
of um you know King f8 King G7
I agree I was just worried that white
would come in with some moves the temple
like say with check
I guess now we could go there but right
now it's on the F7 Pawn's extremely weak
yeah
yeah this is a very concrete position
the players have played relatively
quickly
um and are there more moves on the board
or no no that's it the position is here
after he takes C5 yeah this is the last
this is the current position
um and my gut reaction here is is that
black is running more wrists than white
is in this position because of how wide
open the black king is but white has
very weak pawns and and black has the
bishop pair so black has some strategic
advantages in return for some short-term
tactical problems which could end in you
know instantaneously losing the game
is a very very strong Grand Master and
he sees things very very quickly
so I I can't imagine he walked into this
position without having some idea but
it's certainly very dangerous for black
it seems quite
as I agree
thinking just now I know it's a little
bit again my Bishop someone will start
telling me something I just played or
someone might have even said it in one
of the chats like just play the names of
it you just give up your your Bishops
every five seconds but um we just do
this and then if you capture now I'll
give Queenie one check you're going to
try to avoid the queen trades right like
I believe because the pawn structure is
going to to be quite bad for an end game
and then after this move I was thinking
maybe we could give this check I don't
know how much
we can survive this with black butt or
maybe we could even capture no it would
be too much
because there's still this check and
so we need to escape
this cannot be
this cannot be something playable for
black it looks really really dangerous
but again I mean the black king can get
to f8 and G7 so you know Bishop G4 here
so if you play Bishop check King f8 King
G7
there's nothing instantaneous here
I was thinking
and cute but I do like your ideas
slightly better than my
then um and even you know if you move
the D Rook to F1 I mean you could lose
the D4 Pawn I don't know that if I was
black I would be anxious to grab that
right away because it opens another line
but it loosens it
and you're not checkmating immediately I
mean black can bring well black black
also has another problem here at the
bishop on B5 is that Rook on A8 can't
get to either say d8 and D7 or to E8 to
guard the F7 square right
so that pawn on D5 and the bishop on B5
are you know making a little bit harder
for black to guard F7 with one of the
Rooks
it would have to
there are a couple of moves behind but
they might be able to make it yeah but
we have to say that actually there was a
move that was played here and Aram went
for the natural Bishop D7 in this
position it seems like he did not want
to go into complications he might
consider just castling long potentially
that way his King will get out of Harm's
Way
maybe go into some other Harm's Way
um
yeah actually that is a move that's just
so natural I don't know why we were
thinking so
aggressive so it was me it was me well
I've been I've been taking this I've
been uh watching uh I've been spending
some time on Chesterville and I I I got
the Judith Polgar
um
one of the Judy Polgar courses and she's
focusing on these you know checks
captures you know variations and threats
and everything so I I'm looking for
those four singles I'm just you know not
more when you read something and you're
so excited about it then you just do
that you think that's the only way it's
the natural reaction in these positions
to look for check capture threat and
that's sort of when you're analyzing the
the first things to look at
well now it seems like the position is
calming down a little bit I don't see
concrete ways for white at the moment to
be able to still um
to keep well maybe this check
but other than that
um I guess well it's dangerous
um what will you do with the king is uh
is going to be the question because
I believe after this we could be we we
could have more more threats that either
that or maybe we could just go D6 first
just sacrifice the pawn
to keep yeah I think black again with
King f8 King G7 it's not that easy to
get to the king and now you have the E8
Square for The Rook where you didn't in
the line we were looking at where the
bishop was not on D7
so as dangerous as this looks for black
the king's pretty safe on f8 and G7 here
now White's obviously going to move his
white squared bishop and put a rook on
F1 but Black's going to get a Tempo with
rookie eight yeah that I was trying to
figure out where to put the bishop
because in D3 I'm just blocking the
queen and after rookie eight I might
have to trade Queens
which I'm not sure I I won so I guess I
could go here
to keep the option open to retreat with
my queen
if you're going to attack me to just go
back
for example right
um you know and then here black can play
you in something like say well the
Queen's a little loose so we have to be
careful about the black queen I'm uh I'm
still I'm still thinking their ideas for
black to to have some some ideas with
with Tempo here which will be kind of
unpleasant
Bishop F5
and
eventually I will make my move I'm very
lucky
I really want to make that move somehow
you know
um
did we miss anything no I mean there's a
comment here about Queen E4 check Bishop
b76 looks more interesting I think black
the the King on f8 to me looks safer
um because we're getting the The Rook on
A8 into play and a Sabine is pointing
out we're also getting the bishop to F5
potentially with threats and so that
Bishop on B4
um
gives us the attack on the Knight on D2
and we've kept our Queen on F2 which is
you know potentially supporting Bishop
F5 so so maybe bishop E7 is objectively
a better move but the idea of black
potentially being able to hit all the
white pieces while White's not also
fully developed is pretty appealing but
you know I mean in this position after
Bishop E7 so it's true that move keeps
the option open to Castle long but in
the same time if you place the bishop
there
um you're stuck you cannot Castle so I
don't need to be to make this decision
Rush decision to think oh I'm going to
put pressure on the bishop so that you
cast along and let's just show that line
for the audience and then so that you
have this move for example and and hit
my Rook right I could just not go why
would I do that because right now you're
stuck right now I can't actually capture
the bishop right so maybe I'll just make
a good development move because that's
what we're taught developer I really
wanted to play that move but I'm just
being a little bit too aggressive right
now
um I'm I'm trying to be Yasser style and
and do you know just make moves because
I know they're not my pieces I've heard
him make that joke so I hope but but
here you might consider Bishop C4 or C4
yeah it threatens to play D6 because now
you're threatening Rook hf1 immediately
after
so and black doesn't have the option of
Bishop D6 here so Bishop C4
now black can maybe play Bishop F5 here
or queen F5 but but that's maybe Queen
F5 Bishop F5
very um I would be very happy
position with the white I believe
because I don't see a con like a
follow-up well you can play F6 and
you're trying to say queen takes C7 Rook
C8
yeah but yeah you're you're falling
apart yeah you're losing everything here
because The Bishop's Garden I'll take
everything yeah yeah that's what I say
you're losing everything here I don't
think oh
it was one of those things right it
looked it looked a little bit suspicious
for white grabbing everything
that didn't work out that didn't work
out very well okay it's fine it's fine
we're gonna be more mindful about it
okay now we know that's a threat we're
gonna be more mindful okay so um let's
be careful about that but I don't know
but you see that's why I wanted to put
the bishop in D3 you know what I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna stay straight what
I was gonna say is though I'm not so
sure that trading Queens is awful if
white can somehow take advantage of the
development and maybe white can't
here you know after Bishop C4 Bishop F5
whether I just Retreat the queen back uh
you want to just go back by the way well
to E1 I want my Rook on the open file
but
um I mean yeah I don't know if it is a
possible idea I do want to grab some
material first but I could be wrong
okay it might just be a terrible idea
but why why would we want to trade
Queens when when Black is struggling
with the king in the center and really
now he cannot Castle so just Bishop D3 I
feel that should give white sufficient
sufficient play here
um you're looking one
can come in next because well not yet
still we cannot go looking one because
whenever we'll take
then there'll be rookie eight and
they'll be right I think you can play
Brook hf1 here yeah we'll go here this
is this is the threat in this position
Rook hf1 so what about let's just say
black is greedy and just decides to take
the spawn in this position
I think I want to put a rook on F1
um
laughs
maybe we can go Rook
H to F1 I think the H root makes the
most sense here
you have to I'm sorry
okay but yeah I would say this position
is extremely unclear here and again it's
it's very concrete
but black is somehow stuck I don't know
if I would feel comfortable going back
going back with the bishop to E7 yeah
pinning a piece doesn't feel right it
doesn't feel right and it's good to keep
the bishop for threats although you know
we're joking about it quite a lot but
um but in some situations you know you
have to give up a bishop for a night and
um I think for black trading off to an
end game this would be a dream come true
because
um especially if it's like bishop and
games or King and Pawn
definitely totally winning the king will
just come and and grab every single Pawn
is going to be very easy so you want to
try to keep as many pieces on the board
as possible
um okay I think we focus on this game a
lot and people want to see more more
stuff and I think I saw a question about
um the the why we're not showing the
players playing
um I think this time around we will not
be showing the the playing haul however
we will have
um live interviews as some of the games
are finishing I know we have someone
um
on site who's going to take interviews
with some of the players and we will be
showing them in studio so
um you know you you guys will have the
chance to see some of the players if
there's someone in particular you would
like us to interview feel free to let us
know in any of the chat twitch or
YouTube and we'll try our best to get
your favorite players interviewed and
shown on the broadcast
but we I cannot promise you that I'm I'm
just you know I'm just a commentator for
the moment but I'll try my best to to
talk to the right people so that you
guys get get to see your favorites
um live but anyways looks like we had
another move but people are asking for
more games so is there any specific game
that maybe someone in the chat can tell
us or maybe you Doug have yeah why don't
we just go in order and then you know
internet we'll get the first 10 games in
and then we'll try and pick round as the
games progress sounds good so we'll go
to board five Lazar brazon against
um Aaron Jacobson and
um there was
some of you may have joined us a little
bit later and
we wanted to let you know once again
there is a delay there is a 30-minute
delay in the broadcast so
um yes
in the games the broadcast yeah yeah we
are live we're live I apologize I'm
being told
um I mean I know they were like we are
live the games are shown 30 minutes
later
um the delay is 30 minutes all right
hopefully that cleared things up for
everyone
great great all right so let's see let's
catch up with the moves because we spend
quite a lot of time and I think some of
these games are getting out of the uh
the opening quite soon what is this H6
move
um I think that Jacobson brothers are um
um sometimes coming up with very
interesting new ideas that's definitely
not a topical line people typically take
here or something Bishop E7 I don't know
what else maybe check is an option two
in this Catalan but I I can't say I've
never seen H6 before but I personally
don't understand the move at all because
there's no variation where white is
going to play Bishop G5 or Knight G5
immediately oh let me tell you you gotta
be corrected by Sabina but that's okay I
lost the game myself in 95 so what
happened is
um
I had to learn the cat how to play
against the Catalan and I thought I knew
that perfectly crystal clear so what I
did is I set up my position with
I don't know exactly how it was but it
was something with C6 B6 you know Bishop
E7 castle and then I put my Bishop in D7
1986 and then the trade happens
um my opponent goes E4 a trade happens
here he takes back with the Knight and
then I think I can play C5
I think I can place E5 your c95 is not
possible trust sure right they have
Knight F6 and Knight G5 but you may take
all your pieces on the queen side I I
fell for that and after that I just
couldn't sleep you know for days yeah
that's an issue with chess you make
moves like that and you think about them
all night and it's a real issue that's
that's really yeah so but normally no I
totally agree with you I would be a
little concerned about playing H6
because a lot of times in the closed
cattle and lines whites got more space
on the king's side so as you know Sabina
said white would angle for E4 with some
combination of say Knight bd2 Queen C2
and E4 and and then and then eventually
play E5 if black doesn't capture on e4
and then that H6 move provides a hook
for white to play G4 G5 in the future
and this is a plan that takes many moves
it's not like white can go directly for
that but it does create a long-term
Target I agree and a lot of the open
Catalan lines you can't afford to waste
a Tempo with H6 I agree so it's It Again
The Jacobson brothers look at this stuff
very deeply so I'm sure that it's got
its points but it's not a move that I
understand
I don't either but let's see let's see
what uh what they have planned maybe
maybe we'll we'll come up with the we'll
try to understand
we'll try our best to understand the
difference and how this move could be
useful for black in some situations but
anyways I think it is important for our
viewers to know that whatever opening
they are trying to learn they should
make sure they become familiar with the
different themes and tactical ideas
would you agree uh Doug yeah because if
you're not familiar with them even if
you think you know you know the moves
and everything you have to know the
tactics because you're typically taught
the main lines not the sidelines and
oftentimes in Sidelines there can be
some
you know rights discoveries that you're
not aware of and you should definitely
make sure you study some of those as as
you go along
okay and to me this is an interesting
decision already with C takes D5 because
the idea that I was talking about of
playing you know for Knight bd2 Queen C2
and E4 you've decided not to do that now
luzon's a much better player than I am
so and typically in these Queens Indian
structures when you have to recapture
the pawn on D5 black is strategically
worse
but
so I think it's kind of combining maybe
um this this idea is very typical in
Queens Gambit declined to capture the
exchange variation so you or or just
like normal normal Queens can be
declined you typically take there as
soon as black plays B6 because you know
they're going to develop the bishop
there and by making this move you don't
get the Carlsbad structure you don't get
to play C6 anymore so now you are kind
of forced more or less to figure out a
way to to hide this
weakness that you've created for
yourself so I wonder if he's just trying
to combine those two ideas somehow
with this trade but that's that's the
only thing I can think of I totally
agree with you that I would want to to
play for that but maybe it's difficult
now that black doesn't have the pawning
C6 and his Bishop will be will be able
to control it for maybe he just thought
it would be difficult to get that right
yeah and black you know might be playing
for C5 here to um you know get rid of
the weaknesses
trade all the center
um I'm curious to see if at some point
white is going to place a 1985 and try
some F4 probably it's not gonna work
here so so well the Pillsbury idea
Bishop A3
okay
trades
Queen E7 this Knight has to come back
into play it's actually interesting in
other variations for black too sometimes
this Knight goes to A6 maybe in
um like London system or something well
in the Queen's Indian there's yeah it's
with 96 and C5
no but um what I was trying to say is
this Knight doesn't doesn't go back to
C2 now you don't want you there's
nothing to do here so you always have to
think about the future of it so it seems
like
um Lazaro is going for Knight B5 with
Tempo and then whenever that Knight will
be chased he's bringing it back to C3
this is the place where the Knight wants
to be you may think you're saving some
move by just taking it to C2 but since
you don't have a follow-up to it I
believe that's the reason why he he goes
there right I mean White's created you
know the potential for a hanging Pawn
structure here now after C5 and
I I mean I think white normally you know
has an advantage if they can get the
bishop to G2 in these hangy Pawn
structures because black doesn't have a
favorable way to resolve the tension in
this position
I agree yeah so white is well placed
actually in case these ink case black
considered considers to take which they
shouldn't but in case that trade happens
uh black will stay with an isolated Pawn
which white is perfectly placed with the
pieces to attack it with the minor
pieces oftentimes you don't get that
this bishop is usually you need to so it
takes you for quite some time but but
white white will have a great position
then
but here um do you think do you think
white will go maybe Rook C1 and try to
capture so that he gets two hanging
pawns and start putting pressure on them
yes with white pieces be placed
correctly to attack I think so and also
when you have the hanging pawns you want
to keep as many pieces on the board as
you can I agree and so strategically
White's traded off one set of minor
pieces here and in particular the black
squirt Bishop gone the C5 Pawn is is
softer mm-hmm but he will probably go
Roxy one then come back bring the Knight
here to put pressure he has to come up
with a way to bring this queen to attack
C5 typically I think this would be a
great location for it if you could bring
it there so you you technically try
right to uh from my knowledge to attack
um one of the hanging pawns to make it
push forward so that you can blockade
them right so I think that will be do
you think the C5 will be the one that
we're trying to attack or default I
think it's C5 and white can also after
Rook C1 put the Rook on C2 which then
gives flexibility to move the queen you
know either to B1 or A1 and to bring the
other queen or to C1 and A3 as Sabine is
pointing out here so you know Rook C1
Rook C2 which also guards E2 makes a lot
of sense to me because it then gives
white a lot of different avenues for
putting pressure and and it's hard to
see how
black is going to strengthen his
pressure against the white E2 Pawn
I agree so I I think white is
strategically better in these positions
but there's still a big fight go ahead
that's right well I think
uh we're hitting about an hour since we
started streaming so we are going to
take a short break and we'll be back
with more games to show you
um meanwhile we are going to have
we're going to show you something
a preview of the American Cup stay with
us see you soon
great thank you the St Louis chess
club's 2023 chess season launches in
March for the second annual American Cup
world-class Chess Masters will gather in
the chess capital of America St Louis
Missouri to compete in a double
elimination tournament for a combined
three hundred thousand dollars in prizes
we will cover all the action live from
the World Chess Hall of Fame from March
17th through March 26th tune in for the
best game in chess streaming live for
more information visit uschesschamps.com
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
way to lose weight I mean why
the only thing I would say is
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everyone I'm feeding Master
Doug Eckert and I'm here with women's
welcome back to our coverage of the San
Luis super Swiss event
and before we go back to looking at the
games everyone has requested to see the
pairing so they should be up on your
screen here shortly there they are and
this is a hundred percent of the players
in the tournament and the pairings
and
as we were on break there was lots of
requests for us to look at one of the
local player favorite Players Bar at
kobian's game so we're going to start by
going to varicobian we're gonna we're
gonna go to that so once again we have
41 players playing and you guys see the
pairings for everything
um on your screen still
um we were we before the break we took a
look at the first five boards we we saw
Elia newshnik against Josiah stirman
Irene sukhandar against
Park Alice lead against Aram hakobian
that was a really exciting game and then
we finished off with uh with Lazaro
brazona's game against Aaron Jacobson
but since there were a lot of requests
about
some of the local players here one of
the most famous ones of varicobion seems
to be a favorite
will get directly to it right and I also
wanted to answer another question
question the chat here someone asked
about us looking at one of Costa
kubwitzki's games unfortunately Costa is
on one of the boards that's not on gdt
so we're not able to see his game so
we're nuts we're only able to see the
top 10 boards and those will be the
games that we're commenting on that's
right for the moment that's what we are
doing and
um I don't think we're gonna pull up the
schedule but for those of you who are
joining in late or maybe we can pull up
the schedule of the tournament so the
rounds take they're two rounds a day
besides the last day when there's just
going to be the one and final round so
each day the rounds starts at 11 A.M and
5 p.m and um last day March 16th
the last round will still starts at 11
A.M for the commentary part that the we
are going to go over the odd number
games only so we'll be live for round
one three five seven and nine I'm told I
will be joined by another co-host which
makes me sad because I wasn't aware of
it
we found that out earlier but we'll see
who that will be but until then we will
be here hopefully you'll be here with me
tomorrow as well right yes all right so
we'll go over
um the games for round three and there
is a delay in the games we are live
however but the games are delayed by 30
minutes that's how you guys showed up
see them and you can follow the
broadcast of the games on leeches
so I just pulled the game between
varacobian and I see he's playing
against Nicolas ladan and actually no
Nicolas last year I was the head of the
delegation of the US team for World
youth championships and Nicholas was the
U.S representative for
um
boys under 18. so I got the chance to
see some of his interesting games there
and I think he was uh he was getting
ready to go to college I think he has
just one more year he's finishing
uh this year and his high school and
he's playing against varakobian so let's
let's catch up with the moves
I'm sure you know a lot about VAR yeah
and Report VAR is an extremely good
friend of mine we hang out together
quite frequently so I I know VAR very
well he's a very popular player he's a
very solid player and um
he's certainly looking forward to
playing more chess in the last couple
years he's spent a lot of time with the
commenting crew here in St Louis and he
would like to play more chess he also
has two young children at home which
makes playing chess more complicated
that's right but then maybe even more
exciting too because sometimes when uh
when you have
um I I don't have kids so obviously I
can't talk about it but but when I was
when I was a student for example
sometimes I would really enjoy playing
chess more when I could get off my
school duties obviously it's not the
same I'm not trying to say it's the same
it's totally different but sometimes
when I had to
um when I was finishing with an exam and
I had to go play chess it was like so
exciting and I was so much much more
motivated for chess then so hopefully
we'll see we'll see if are doing well in
this event uh looks like he's he's he
went for the exchange variation of the
Queen's Gambit Bishop G5 I play this oh
Bishop B4 right we're seeing this I was
about to say but we're not seeing H6 G5
is the follow-up we're not we're not
looks like H6 was played but VAR went
for the line Bishop takes that well in
the Alice League game she had played
Queen C2 and not and the Knight was here
as well
the night was enough yes yes
so it's a little different a little bit
different than that game so this is this
is quite uh theoretical
Queen takes Queen A4 check
actually Queen A4 check I thought it was
I could be wrong I thought it was Queen
C2 or queen B3 but I could be wrong this
this this is for sure another line
um so what you're trying to do with
white you're trying to attract the
Knight to come to C6 which will stop the
spawn from supporting
um
the D5 yes right and uh and once that
move is played eventually this queen
will be out of place there but it's done
a good job of restricting black from
playing c6o
um that's that's all what we're trying
to do with white with Queen A4 right but
VAR is a very classical player he plays
for Pawn structure positions and he
understands these positions extremely
well coming from someone who's played
hundreds of Blitz Games with him he
knows how to play these positions
tremendously well
okay so yeah no I'm not saying I'm sure
I'm sure I I wasn't familiar with with
this movie exactly here that's why I was
a little bit surprised but um I know
it's it's a move like I know it's a move
earlier maybe hear people sometimes well
maybe you're just translated they're not
they're not in a normal regosan because
they're black Whitehead and played
Knight F3 yet so I think what he was
trying to do was to transpose into a
ragozen type structure that he was
familiar with and I I don't think theory
is all that important of R here what's
important to him is is that he gets a
structure that he's happy with and that
he feels like he can outplay his
opponent
and to me you know Rook to d8 looks a
little strange suspicious yes normally
you would want the Rook on E8 in these
structures but he's
guarding the D5 Pawn is a precautionary
thing you know so in White Castles and
the night's not pen
he doesn't necessarily have to take the
Knight on C3 although ultimately I
believe that black did take the Knight
on C3
first when I saw the move I thought
maybe he's trying to do something like
this but I don't think that would make
any sense at all
um in some situations
um I think Fisher came up with that idea
but it was with white and the reason he
would bring the bishop and I think in
that game was in E1 is because there was
a pawn that the bishop was locked so he
brought out his his F rook and then he
brought the bishop to E1
um but but here no that would be that
would be silly for black to do yeah it's
probably okay but the rook's a little
passive on d8 in that now you have a
rook on A8 and it's hard to see exactly
what you're going to do with the Rook on
A8
I wonder if he's going to try to to push
the pawns on the queen side
somehow
so he took in C3 because he wanted to
move the Knight and then get that
structure with C6 potentially
and now he's trying to take advantage of
his Queen in F6 to play Queen to G6
hit this Pawn
Castle
I guess Bishop H3 wouldn't be doing much
because in 91 looks like it was actually
played
and what do we have over here who is
better
it's
um
I prefer white I don't know if black
has some but how does white get
untangled from here just Bishop F3 and
then try to get the Knight away or do
you think kavar is going to try to trade
Queens
yeah I mean why maybe bishop here white
can play King H1 here and ask black
where
he wants to put his Bishop
[Music]
and then I mean normally you'd want the
Rooks on B1 and C1 if you're a white
here and you've you've already made a
Tempo move with Rook C1
otherwise he played Rook C1 in that
position
no he he played it he played it here he
had to yeah couldn't he he had Bishop E2
and castling without con you know
forcing The Rook because there's always
a rule when you're developing your
pieces you know what pieces do you know
that they go to a square versus what
piece are you undecided where it should
go and to me in this position you know
your Bishop's going to go to E2 but
you're less certain where you want that
Rook on A1 at this point so I agree
I I would think that Bishop E2 is a
little bit more accurate and that gives
you a little bit more flexibility but
maybe if you had played Bishop E2 maybe
black wouldn't have wouldn't have gone
for for the capture or maybe VAR didn't
didn't expect that the capture were
gonna happen so he was just getting
ready to to put some pressure on the
file and actually is it do you think
do you think Rook takes would have been
uh well Brook takes makes more sense if
you put the Rook on C1 but yeah and then
try to go some something like this and
this is going to keep black from moving
the Knight anytime soon I wonder why VAR
and It's Tricky he probably spent some
time here actually can we see how fast
this played this move after the takes he
did spend about five minutes here
supposedly if this times that we're
getting are corrected typically they are
correct
um he he's decided how to capture
because I guess he was not anticipating
this move
um since white didn't have any threat of
moving the Knight just yet black would
have waited maybe one more move with
something some Bishop development
and he probably didn't anticipate that
this was going to happen and I guess he
finally decided that it was better to
take with the pawn instead of The Rook
it's interesting it just has to do with
the choice with or preference of of Pawn
structure
right and and normally this Pawn
structure at B take C3 if black doesn't
have his white squared Bishop it's very
difficult to defend but with black
having the white squirt Bishop it tends
to be less effective for white
um
because the bishop can drop back and
guard the queen side but again black has
that Rook on D A instead of E8 so so
they both have sort of misplaced their
Rooks a little bit here
so C5 was played actually this is the
current position that we are seeing
right now after C5
black is trying to I guess trade all of
these Pawns
and get into a
and just equalize
the position
could we just take
is there something that black has
planned to regain his Pawn down
in this position
yeah that that looks like a very strong
move to me
I'm a little bit confused as to why C5
was played that fast
because I'm not I'm not seeing a way for
for black to get the pawn back what what
am I missing
is black considering but then we can
take it the bishop right and then
or the brook I was just thinking maybe
maybe black wants to bring in The Rook
somehow like this just to just to be
creative with with a potential attack
but right but I was also thinking I
could bring my Rook over too if I take
but where
okay yes you're right you're right you
can
um but
I just wear exactly H4
maybe age four to chase that annoying
Bishop away I have H4 F4 I mean I have
options it also gives me the option of
doubling The Rook somewhere or coming to
D4 and
yeah it's
what are we not seeing here in this
position is there some kind of D takes
C5 looks like a very strong E4 what
about this
what about this move but if I just
so my idea is just to let you with that
because you're talking about Pawn
structures right and VAR being I think
VAR is more of a he's more of a would
you say he's more of a positional or
tactical player he's a position that's
what I thought that's more positional
I've seen him play some some attacking
tactical games but
um so maybe maybe if he does that maybe
I go D4 against against these
and my point is now that if you capture
maybe Rook takes
and
um
I'm just leaving you with the extra Pawn
I'm aware of that but maybe it's not
going to be easy for for white to hold
on to these ponsons the pawn structure
got a little bit
okay so yes you take and I put my king
on H1 to force you to commit the bishop
somewhere
um
I know it's could I make an in-between
move or no
um then I put the bishop on F3 and I'm
hitting your um B7 and
I'm controlling the queening square if I
take it which seems highly dangerous for
black okay let's let's try some I I have
some some ideas probably terrible
uh
you're right you're you're guarding the
Knight or you're trapping the knight in
yeah I was thinking to maybe do
something like this but it's probably
just
just too much dreamy I I need to move my
Rook first of course now and then yeah
you start marching that pawn I cannot
afford to let you do that so I guess
after King H1 I do need to move my
Bishop somewhere
uh would would this be well but if you
go to E6 you're putting some pressure on
the C4 Pawn so you're I mean it's
guarded three times
and you're also leaving room for The
Rook to come around Knight F3 looks like
the most obvious move yeah but can I
play something stupid like rook g495 and
I pork you on the game's over yeah
that's that's what I was worried about
that's I didn't want to that's why I
wanted to go here
um but this could allow for the trade
and then the question is do we capture
with the Rook or with the queen maybe
with the queen
and now
um if you go for example Knight F3
I still I
um
Knight F3 let's play no I can't
I can't do that okay
maybe rookie right Rook F4 I mean this
looks really crude and uh primitive but
sometimes those things work
um I mean if nothing else
Rook C3 or queen V3 I was thinking to
bring the queen back but the queen
sometimes can have ideas there too okay
I want to go Rook C8 eventually get my
Pawn back it's it's going to be a game
it's going to be a game where black has
given up a pawn but it's a double Pawn
so as long as black doesn't lose this
one can I just hit you with Rook f
yeah so I'm not sure if it leads to a
Perpetual check but I believe it should
be right right okay so that was my point
you play Rook C3 first because I want
this idea if I can of Rook fe1 to trade
with their Rooks would this do anything
or not
we're really far ahead it seems like VAR
did not take in C5 I wonder if this is
the reason why he did not go for it
um people are saying people are saying
this looks good for white
um it is a little bit scary I'm not
quite sure if I would yeah because if
you move the Rook off the C file the C4
Pawn drops off so I I think I want to
stray here I think you know sabina's
move a queen B3 might be a better idea
but we're really far we're really far
out yeah but but this was an interesting
I I actually Wonder maybe we can put the
engine for just one second to see if D4
was even something so just wow I'm
amazed that it's actually suggested it
still it still seems that it's it's plus
it says
yeah we'll go go back and move here just
to see what it says Queen E3 the move
that war played actually is the choice
of the engine in this position okay
so I I think this this is certainly
um this is certainly kind of interesting
to to keep in mind I mean it might not
be good but since black is having a
tough position I guess actually before
C5 yeah it still was saying that it was
much better for white this position so
despite the fact that white retreated
with the Knight here to protect you too
um
they are having I mean we knew that we
knew that VAR was having a better
position we just weren't quite sure why
he took with the pawn and it has The
Rook here but maybe it will help him in
the end to to open up the sure the file
and get the look into play but but I
guess
um for people who end up just um getting
into slightly worse positions but they
have to remember to do is not give up
and try to come up with ways to make it
difficult for their opponents so what we
suggested with D4 maybe
um could have created some kind of
counter play for black and
um get his opponents so Nicolas would
get VAR into maybe a type of position
that he wasn't
as comfortable with and virus like no
I'm not going to do that I'll play Queen
A3 this is a nice tactical idea we see
the the pawn is now pinned you can't you
can't take and we we still keep the
option opened of capturing whenever we
want to so he's just making uh
um this move would be good for some
situations as well if you're not careful
if the spawn gets to be moved
um so it's um
sure and also it leaves open the
possibility of you know after say Rook
ac-8 to place C takes D5 and Rook takes
C5 to keep the nice structure intact for
white while winning a pawn right
while leaving all the weaknesses for
black on the queen side and I like this
move very much not rushing
um
yeah that that seems natural but it's
it's the first thing that you have to
think about I think maybe one day we'll
get the chance to ask him if if he
thought about that move at all or not
but um
um anyways
Let's uh let's see um so this is the
current position many of you have asked
um us to show
um this game talk talk about it we did
where shall we why don't we go see
Christopher you and Gabriella on Togo
let's do that Christopher is one of the
very talented young up-and-coming
players and Gabriella is a player in the
St Louis University team Christopher won
the U.S junior Championship last year
and also had a very good showing in the
U.S Championship I don't remember his
exact score but I thought he was around
even which in that field is a tremendous
score yeah he's he's played uh very well
I know he's training a lot
um and uh he's uh he's very famous for
his uh solving puzzles very fast he
wasn't able to Dethrone to disron uh
Grand Master Ray Robson but uh you know
he's still he's still well he not only
solves them but he also creates puzzles
and having spent a little bit of time
around Christopher I mean the ability
that he has to create positions just in
his mind that are fascinating to solve
it's unbelievable to watch him do it and
he's so quick that's awesome that's
awesome has he shared any I I don't know
I know he's entered some of his puzzles
in uh the puzzle contests around the
world so and I think he he might have
meddled which is very hard to do because
this is a very specialized area of Chess
I think he finished second I believe he
finished I know Ray Robson won the the
puzzle Rush competition but that's a
different thing I'm talking about
another these deep puzzles where you you
have like a position like a position
where white can win in seven moves or
black can win in six I see okay he
creates these puzzles and he's got an
extraordinary talent for it and it's
it's something that I don't think most
chess players can just sit there and do
and say I'm going to create a position
and it's going to be hard to solve and
he can do it in his mind and then he
computer checks it and he's right a high
percentage of the time which to me is a
talent that I've never had and I can't
do it I agree that that is brilliant I
wasn't aware he he was composing things
I know a few chess players who are who
are composing a lot
um and uh and are are great but um yeah
I know longer time ago before the era of
computers I thought that was brilliant
that they composed all these positions
without the computer they checked and it
was correct
um so so now you know now with the
computer some of those you can still
find mistakes in in some of the
composition but but it's awesome awesome
to hear that well hopefully one day I'll
get to see some of his some of his
composition but let's get back to the
game so he's playing against Gabriela
antova and they played again at Queen's
Indian
okay so so Christopher compared to the
other game we saw
um went for Bishop E7 not Bishop A6
and someone's asking who the composer
was and it's Christopher you who's
playing Black in the game that we're
looking at here he's you know made a
number of Chess compositions and you
know one of the great talents in
American chess right now yes
and how old is he actually I don't know
he's he's 15 I believe he'll be 16 this
year okay
a five Castle this is Theory Bishop G5
okay yeah so Australia Castle we
typically want to move this bishop or if
it's a knight
sometimes so you have to decide if
you're going to take or not so
Christopher decided to play A5 and hold
on to the bishop there
are lines where where white ends up
taking here but I think even if it seems
that this Pawn structure could be
somehow good for for white because this
Pawn is kind of uh
week supposedly it won't be because I
think sometimes black ends up playing C5
and they would have a that that would be
totally fine at that point I don't think
ever gets captured maybe in some lines
or not I would hate this position as
white or white I mean black has pressure
on the a file and black he has space and
it's very hard to dissipate that
favorably
um and sometimes sometimes white ends up
playing A3 as well to kind of force
black to make a decision whether they're
going to capture the bishop or go back
to to E7
um I don't know what Christopher had
planned in this position if he were to
capture but I think typically they end
up capturing here and then we capture
and then White Castles Queen C2 B3 the
screen sometimes ends up there
um and um
and the fight will still be over the
FourSquare typically
okay so Bishop G5 Bishop E7 all right
Knight C3
Knight E4
okay we have to take
and queen C2
so so far everything everything's normal
actually it's F5 not not to move in this
position I guess it's not
why not
why is this not a move is 92 I think we
have to be worried about with black well
it's a move but
I don't know that black is really going
to get a king side attack in these
structures I I've tried to play the
classical Queens Indian before or the
classical F5 line and corchinoy played
some amazing games with that in the late
70s but
it's it's also a weakening move for
black too to play yeah yeah I think it
depends also in this position black
doesn't have the dark Square uh Bishop
anymore like they would have it in the
Dutch so so it's going to be even harder
because sometimes you want to play uh D6
97 and then push E5 even and without the
bishop it might be more difficult so I
can't point to an immediate problem with
it but I would be worried about playing
F5 in this position as well I see
okay so takes and then Queen takes of
course Pawn takes doesn't make much
sense here for white when you can keep a
good Pawn structure
and now D6 yeah so 97 right yeah if I'm
Gabriella played Bishop G5 if black
plays H6 is white compelled give up the
dark Spirit bishop and the answer is
probably yes
um there's not a convenient spot to drop
the bishop back to
um you could put the bishop on F4 but it
doesn't really perform any function
there and it will ultimately get chased
away so I think
you're probably forced and I guess the
question coming out is is the bishop
pair advantageous for for black in this
position
uh I don't think so because uh I think
white gets in E4 if you're trying to
stop white from going E4
um you will have to go D5 in which case
capture and your Bishop is gonna be
stuck there again
um or maybe we don't even take maybe we
go for the the idea that you and I have
discussed in another game with Queen C2
and trying to go E4 without capturing
um I think this queen is definitely
potentially misplaced in F6
with the bishop having to go back there
I don't think you can put in right they
should be here yeah no I think that's
very good Sabine I believe that's
showing why H6 is a mistake there for
black because while it gains the bishop
pair white is then going to gain space
and all of Black's pieces are going to
be misplaced here yeah the the
coordination is going to be difficult
because you definitely want a knight to
come to F6 and so that's that's probably
the reason why Christopher went back
Bishop B7 because if you choose to take
right now with white in F6 then instead
of having a queen in F6 we have a bishop
and this bishop can potentially go back
to G7 so it's going to be super well
placed having double fianchiato Bishops
controlling the center the center is
open and black will have various ways to
to open up the center with one of these
pushes which they can decide later based
on what white does
um so that's why he went for for it so
hopefully we answered the question was
there any anything else that that was
asked
um no I mean I think people make
comments draw or C5 is a thread if we go
forward I mean yeah
yeah
so let's catch up with the with the game
so Bishop Bishop E4 was played here
Knight H4 this is quite typical in some
situations white tries to avoid the
trade of the Bishops and I know I've
tried on a number of occasions to do
that myself but you're wasting quite
some moves so you're doing this and then
I guess I don't even know if F5 is an
option right now for black
oh maybe I can just go here and then
Knight D2 is the point of this and then
try to get E4
without allowing the trade of the bishop
sometimes having the Bishops on the
board could be annoying for black
because they're lacking space so what do
you think about this yeah I mean this
might be slightly better for white
do you think black would consider taking
here cons given that
you wasted wasted so instead of 97 I
don't think I was thinking about that
and there's some validity to do that if
you're the higher rated player you're
creating an imbalance in the position
with you know the the knight in Queen
versus the queen and Bishop and
he takes is the general strategy here to
put pressure on the e-file yeah I think
this this is a nice ahead this kind of a
position one time in in a game and and I
was quite comfortable with white
um so
yeah I I think White's generally a
little better here but again there's a
lot of pieces traded but Bishop F1 is
certainly more ambitious yeah
well uh Gabriela is the low rated player
so maybe she's she wants to keep a
balanced position sometimes it's hard
when you're playing against a much
stronger player
the the approach you take to the game I
may ask you what is your your approach
uh when you're playing a stronger player
I I just try to play positions that I'm
familiar with and I found over the years
when I have beaten stronger players it's
because I ended up playing a position I
was familiar with and they didn't happen
to understand it quite as well as I do
I'm not a great tactician but with my
you know correspondence play over the
years I've seen lots of positions and
you know the most recent Grand Master I
beat was you know probably about a year
ago it seems like too long ago but I
haven't played as much recently but we
were playing a Leningrad Dodge and the
Leningrad Dutch is one of these openings
where in the main line where you play D5
and black plays C6 the computer will
tell you that the White's a little
better and as long as you keep all four
minor pieces on the board white can't
really improve but as soon as black
trades one set of minor pieces off the
board now all of a sudden his pawns
become weak and he can't defend and I
had a correspondence game where I had
gotten sort of this exact setup and so I
just sat there and moved back and forth
for seven or eight moves the grand
Masters site I'm going to make something
happen and he traded a minor piece off
the board and I won the game in like
seven or eight more moves is this
because I knew the strategically what
the setup should be so I think when
players are playing high rated players
you should play what you know and you
know so you know think about the results
here don't think about the result just
play what you know and do your best and
and see what happened yeah it's hard
though not to think about the results
sometimes but it's definitely a really
good really good advice to play the
position that you know most and yeah if
you can't forget about the result I
think you're playing more
you have more confidence once you start
thinking about it all these thoughts
about other things come into your mind
and you don't have a clear clear mind to
focus on the game and yeah right and
sometimes you may know the position
better than the much higher rated
players so I think that's okay yeah
okay so Knight H4 and Christopher went
for F5 so now he's going for F5 he
didn't want to take here he's you know I
I often like to tell when I teach I'd
like to tell my students to when they
learn an opening to make sure they're
familiar with the key squares and that
being a key Square
um in the Queen's Indian nimso Indian
you want to avoid allowing white to get
to play E4 so I guess Christopher is
thinking F5 would come perfectly because
when you take which Gabriel ended up
taking he's trying to keep the pawn
there he might get D5 in next move get
in the night and then this Pawn is going
to be annoying for this night you'll
have to bring it back to play through G2
and then
there's some pressure right the night's
very restricted and typically in these
structures you know white would play for
the F3 Pawn break but you know with this
few and minor pieces on the board the
white king is weaker over the long term
and again black can't get to it
immediately but there are weaknesses in
the white position that
you know black has something to play for
in a position that's probably if we
turned on the engine and we're not going
to do that I would guess is pretty close
to equal I'm surprised about this move
you know I think if white wanted to
trade those Bishops she had to go here
this forces the trade I'm assuming she
wanted the Knight there to to be sneaky
and take take back with the Knight but
if she wanted that maybe the Rook
shouldn't have been here she could have
gone back to anyone but even so F5 was
an option so this placement the
placement of the 1985 in H4 allowed
black to play F5 and now
you have to take you can relate because
right G5 is a threat
s you have to be mindful about
um about some things
um
all right so people don't want us to use
the stockfish and we're not using it for
now we might turn it on occasionally but
so Queen E3 so Gabriela is putting
pressure on this one
okay it's actually important here not to
play E3 in my opinion although you might
want to connect your pawns but that's
going to block your queen on this other
side of the board and you need to kind
of have it close to your king I I
absolutely agree that's why I made the
comment that I think white has to play
F3 here to free the position but again
you are weakening the position
so she definitely should not take there
like that should be a no I should make
it red so nope where's the red there's
the red right but I don't believe you're
going to get your pressure on the C file
so
I I think this position is still very
double-edged
um
you know what white can play Rook C3
rookie C1 and threaten C takes D5 but
you know maybe black plays C6 but but
you're gonna you may get the C file
it's interesting to see that uh
Christopher came up with this idea A4 A4
I'm wondering if he wants to bring the
bring the Rook or
because I don't think A3 is uh is he's
his his idea or just stabilize the spawn
and be toot to play maybe there's a call
for us to look at the ninja steerman
game okay I did not hear that call
um but sure where it's board one bar one
all right so let's go to that game let's
see what's going on
oh what what is going on in this
position
wait is it over
because I see some commentary here and
that was normal I'm trying to remember
where we left off in this game I think
you have to go back to move like
yeah we were we were we were really
early I don't know how come these
commentaries stayed here they usually
just disappear yeah I think we we
definitely didn't look at it before
White had played E4 no I don't know
what's with all those comments actually
uh I'm I'm Amazed by by the comments in
the because I didn't make them
um
okay okay so so what happened so we have
um we're talking about this um Hedgehog
kind of position which I don't know is
it Hedgehog if it's not with G6 still
called yeah it's still called the
Hedgehog okay
all right so 9g4 in fact the traditional
Hedgehog is with the pawns the bishop on
E7 B7 the pawns on D6 right yeah in A6
the Knight on A6 is a little weird yeah
well it wants to come possibly here that
would be an extra nice
thing for black queen C2
but is this night going to get into play
eventually
904 so so Elia is going for the for the
bishop pair
so that seemed like a waste of time for
black
but it dragged White Knight on the edge
of the board and then he came back Queen
I don't understand why those arrows are
there I apologize I'm gonna get rid of
every arrow that I see
I like this move 95
and are you saying that these kind of
moves are coming into two they're not
doing anything
maybe not
yeah I mean you always have to be
careful that you're weakening here
because what's your follow-up you know
you don't ever want to play F5
necessarily unless you could calculate
it out to a win and E5 is
yeah he's going to trade The Bishop's
history I don't want to yeah right and
then you're allowing the D6 break and
your King's open so
okay so maybe just develop but Ilya went
for Knight B5 going for
okay
we saw we saw the receipt we saw the the
arrows going for for that
um
for that square
how are you going to stop can you play
T6 here
no yeah D6 looks risky because now
you've opened yourself up to F4 E5 in
some lines not necessarily right away
but
so he played Knight C5 so he allowed he
allowed white to get onto that square
obviously you need to move the Knight
first and I like the Delia went back
um so now this Knight is going to go to
D6 potentially this one just came back
to C3 which was its place anyways
okay now
B4 now he's starting the Palm push
okay F4
yeah and that's a strange move to me to
put the knife back there on C6 instead
of G6 but but I think the problem is
that pawn
it doesn't matter yeah you can grab it
either way
but he didn't grab it it's what's
interesting is that after Knight C6 he
played A3
and
um now black played D6
and why are we getting all these arrows
this is this is annoying and I can't get
rid of them until I get to the move
okay so he did not bring in his Rook
Bishop B2 he's he's probably going to
double up this way this position is so
good for white this Knight is totally
out of play like it if you could just
get it there right right
um and because the 90s and A6 black
can't even play eight six and Chase the
Knight away
Rook d8
oh he went for the Tactical idea
take on D6 and then um
no 95.
he went for the typical a I don't know
if it works it hopefully worked for him
but yeah looks like he won okay so all
those errors and everything were coming
maybe from stockfish or something okay
now the game is over
and we got all the stockfish analysis
um that we can't get rid of
but wow this is nice because I guess if
you take
we take right yeah and what are you
gonna do right The Bishop's saying do
you want a pawn
this is sad if that if he could just
switch at the list you know get the
queen in A8 you know get something but
no that Knight D5 came so beautifully
um this is this is definitely a great
great tactical idea famous for Sicilians
um Bishop f8
Knight F6
and
wow look at that you can't take because
we'll check you first Bishop G7
and mate
[Music]
and after King AJ just Queen H5 and
wow
this is a gorgeous finish and I guess I
wish this move was possible just to
finish the game nicely but it's not it's
not but Queen F7 is just just enough and
um the game I think the game ended here
but I guess we can put a couple more
moves it takes check King G8
and we just take everything
or maybe bishop H3 is an option
but maybe but if you take check and then
the Rook comes in and over
or even takes there and black died with
a lot of pieces on this side of the
board this is
this is this is very sad I feel bad for
for for Josiah because
um
ah this must have been very difficult to
play I've had games when I I put my
pieces I thought I'm doing something but
then I forgot about them I couldn't and
then
you know yeah Italy is a very strong
Grand Master he was very close to 2700
about six months ago and he had a bad
tournament and you know there's like a
comment about when do you know that your
attack is strong enough and I think this
position is a good illustration of it
that if one side gets like a two-piece
Advantage Plus their Queen aimed at your
king you're probably about to get
checkmated and I think this is a very
good example of that that Ilya had two
extra minor pieces aimed at the black
king in the form of the night on D5 and
the bishop on B2 plus the queen and
black essentially had no pieces over
there defending and while it doesn't
look like it's Checkmate that that extra
force and material here should be a good
indication that the white attack might
work
and to be honest I mean this is where I
think you see a grand master and why
they're stronger than Masters like
myself because I I could probably look
at this position for 20 30 minutes and
still not come to a conclusion that
there's a forced wind and he may not
have seen the Forest Wind here but he
knows it's enough yeah he knows the
compensations enough so at some point
it's not that he has to see the end but
he knows no matter what he can't be
worse and he's probably winning yeah
yeah he's he's so confident I mean he
has so much more space and there's no
way he could not have something with so
many pieces on the side of the world
it's both space and force yeah because
he's got a dominance and force on the
king's side
and you know as we see he basically he
gets for the bishop in the night he gets
all three of the the black king side
pawns he gets G7 F7 and E6 and then he
brings in a space for the The Rook to
come sliding over
and and there's no pieces over there to
defend the black king
that was that was a really beautiful
game I do not know if you are going to
have an interview with Ilya later or not
but I suggest a short break and will be
back
um after that stay with us
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back we have a result in one of
our prominent games here with Barbara
cobium so we were going to start by
going through the remainder of that game
and then hopefully get VAR on an
interview here very shortly
yes I hope I'm hoping that we'll be able
to actually hear that interview so you
guys can see the final moves here we
stopped after Queen A3 which we thought
was a very interesting very interesting
idea
and then D takes C4 was played
Queen takes E5
so he took the pawn with the queen we
were saying with the poem but that was
allowing these ideas with uh with a palm
push right well we were also suggesting
that you would keep the pawn structure
intact so we didn't think we didn't look
at D take C4 is one of the possibilities
here we looked at Rook AC 8 and C takes
D5
as a possibility
yeah well no we didn't know I said we
looked at Rook AC 8 for black yeah
and keep the pawn structure intact so I
think this is really the same thing with
Queen takes C5 is that White's keeping
the pawn structure intact
nine to five
King H1
to avoid and and the bishop has to move
now because The Bishop's hanging yeah
but it seems like he forgot to move it
he played Rook C8
Queen A3 and why does it say one zero
why is it
is the game over or I'm confused I think
black men still play right
um
with Bishop G4 F3 G4 here
so the pawn on E3 is guarded
and I'm going to play G4 and you're
you're losing a piece for a pawn because
the bishop on E2 guards everything but
is this is this necessarily resignable
could we not come up with some kind of
counter play I always I always like I
don't like to resign you know nobody
likes to resign but I don't like to
reside that early I'm just all in I I've
played games with much more material
down than just a piece a piece is
nothing
um
I know I guess he's being very
respectful uh Nicholas is like I said a
very young young talented U.S junior and
I guess
he was trying to be respectful
and he has another round in the
afternoon which we are not doing
commentary on right so I mean do you
want to beat your head against the wall
for an hour and a half when you're a
piece down in a position like this but
this to me looks like it's completely
over and I I think he just forgot but
but even if you don't play Rook ac-8
here if we go back to the position after
Queen takes C5 you know the the Knight
on F5 is just in the way
so I but here after no no no we take C5
he played Knight C East F5 so I'm just
saying Knight F5 is in the way it blocks
the bishop in right so maybe going Rook
C8 here the night hangs so I I think
black is just losing a pawn
you have to put the Knight somewhere and
and then white takes the pawn on C4 and
and whites upon up
yeah I don't I don't see what else we
could try to do here in this position
but maybe not Rook C8 I thought you
first meant that not drug C8 do we still
lose something because right now the
queen is not in A3 as soon as the queen
was in A3 and protecting here I
understand the voice came over how about
here do we have at least a little bit
more Chelsea first so now you have more
chess because at least you're getting
the Rook after night we could do E3 hear
and takes we could go for this line
technically or or maybe we could go
Bishop H5 first or no that if we go
Bishop H5 then G4
and no then we're not getting the Rook
right that's not ideal well right right
because the Rook can move and after the
question we could get we could get this
position how
how do I assess this one I'm just trying
to get some some activity a Queenie for
check maybe that pawn is hanging
um
yeah there's but it's white to move here
I mean I can play Bishop to F3 for
example no but I wanna I wanna take the
Rook
uh you want to play Bishop is the right
thing so you have to move here but then
that's gonna be hanging
maybe Rook F4
that's an option like that for sure is
an option
I have too much material down here two
pawns is not sufficient for the piece I
think white will be able to regroup make
sure the king is safe maybe an ig2 get
the bishop to F3 something like that and
sorry fixed it
um but okay
we don't need to do that why would we
not just take an E3 immediately take
stakes and then play this position I
mean obviously it should be better for
white but you know you still have to
prove this to prove it right we can
capture this Pawn this Pawn is hanging
uh White has to coordinate these two
pieces it's not going to be too hard
Knight F3 and then possibly this Pawn is
going to be hanging but I think it takes
some time it'll take some effort but
even like after Rook ac-8 okay I can put
my queen on B4 and I'm gonna Corral in
the C4 pawn and I'm going to have it
okay I'll take that one I'm going to
have it pass d-pawn and that's right and
that past D Pawn I would think would win
the game eventually it's going to take
some effort but
black has a fairly minimal counter play
and and white should be able to get the
pieces coordinated
I agree
I just realized something that we were
not connected on sellers chess clubs
thing so we might not show on leeches
that is the possibility I just realized
so hopefully we'll get that fixed right
but if you think about this position
here White's going to be able to
probably trade one set of Rooks after
Queen B4 Rook takes C4 and then he's
going to have a knight on E5 a bishop on
C4 which is going to tie black down to
the F7 Pawn while the White Queen is
attacking you know the queen side as
well as can put pressure on the king
side so I I don't think this is
technically too difficult to convert for
um for white here
yeah I agree it's not so easy for black
to
but maybe maybe we don't play roxy8 in
this position although what to do
yeah that this this is a good move this
is a good strengthening move right it
just guards everything and if you don't
take my Pawn I mean fine I can play
Knight F3 anyway no I was just
considering maybe we could go Rook C8
first maybe try to capture this Pawn
instead this this is a more dangerous
Pawn than the G4 Pawn it's so in this
case if you go for example if we follow
the same path then I'll take this one so
maybe you don't want to give me that
pawn but then if you're taking A7 I
could try to get my rook in and take the
two pawn and just we would just have a
different kind of position I think
right we could do that I mean white
could also consider Queen E5 here not I
don't know if that's the right idea or
not maybe it's better just to zap the
pawns on the queen side when I can
but I hate to have black with a rook
down on my second rank if I can avoid it
I'm just worried if you play this you
might uh you might be struggling with a
something on the back rank eventually so
I take and then you still want to play
Knight F3 but then now you don't have
control over my C Pawn so I think in
this situation I could just start push a
little more counter play yeah
but um yeah definitely would have given
black more chances so Rook C8 was a
mistake and then after that
um
we've seen Queen A3 a second time that
that virus putting the queen in A3 in
the scheme but this time controlling and
defending the E3 Pawn which now leads to
the trapping of blacks light Square
bishop and he's Upon A resign so I'm I'm
I haven't been told yet if we will have
or if we're having an interview with VAR
or not
um
all right we uh do not have it at the
moment so I suggest going over to
another game another game that was very
interesting that we left off was the
game between Alice Lee and Aram hakobian
um
uh wow lots of things happen from that
crazy position that we had earlier in
the game I would have never guessed that
we could have gotten a rook end game
right out of all end games
um I think we stopped around this move
if you guys remember we were considering
a lot of ways for for white to to try to
take advantage of black skin in the
center with Queen E4 but it seems that
Alice decided to go for Knight E4 okay
so actually if we had State one more
move we would have seen the end game
um happening but yeah now black is kind
of forced to make a trade
you don't really have a choice but it's
a little surprising because black has
the two Bishops and white has a really
lousy Pawn structure here but you know
it seems that white made this work
Castle long I guess um Bishop F5 would
allow Bishop D3 and now white is going
to have double threat and you cannot go
with the King on either side because you
would you would allow for that to happen
unless you go King fate
but then white could still
offer a bishop tree maybe Knight F6
yeah Knight F6 and your king is
centralized and the Knight controls some
nice squares there and if you go to G7
Derby check so obviously you know trade
is happening so maybe white is
comfortable with having a knight versus
the dark swear Bishop sure because with
the Knight on H5 you can play G4 and
black can't really get to the Knight
um
yes yeah and all that pawn structure is
stabilized on the on the king side and
then we can just get on the
way I I don't think black's in any
trouble I mean with the bishop on DC
it's guarding everything I think it's
pretty equal
would be I agree I agree
I would prefer white though I think
after getting to play G4 I'm not even
sure if we need to put the 19 H5
maybe we can just Retreat here or maybe
go 97 95 or something like that but G4
is definitely white should be playing
and just one Pawn keeps three
but black didn't play that no black
castled along here in this position
which allowed Knight F6 so now the trade
ended up happening uh in a similar
fashion just the king ended up being on
the queen side instead so trade Bishop
E7
and
um I guess Alice decided to allow for
the bishop to be given for the night
that's interesting but what could she do
because otherwise she would lose this
Pawn
so she ended up going Group D to F1 with
the idea that after the trade which
seems to happen she would capture this
H6 spawn which I think from these two
which one would you capture
first
yeah because your King's closer to the
F1
but you know if you think about this
variation versus what we first looked at
with um you know playing Bishop 5 first
is black got the root to the D file one
tempo quicker which allowed black to hit
the D5 Pawn so you're probably writing
at other position black is worse and
blacks maintain the quality here because
you know the the black Brook's already
on d8 I agree
I agree so extra Tempo in that position
and it's going towards
um more or less balanced rooken game but
Rook end games
you know they're not always draw like
they tell you you have to fight for it
sometimes depending on the situation
black spawn structure seems to be
slightly better
where the whites doubled g-pawns but
Rook D3 check oh it shows not to capture
here because you probably thought that
after this move
he doesn't have more than draw
am I right
because there's no way for black to do
right I think you just played King C3
here I wonder if you can even try to
play for a win no probably not that
seems inherent because if you're not
careful and just say you try to get you
try to to get the king here and then if
Rook B3 to play B3 or something crazy
like that then or then you would allow
this move to happen well but there's a
back ring well well you're right if the
Rook stays on d8 you can
C4 here yeah yeah I mean maybe you can
still make a
but Alice is probably playing for a draw
at this point because she's playing a
much higher rated opponent so
so see he did not go for those pawns
he's trying to leave those there and
he's trying to get the Rook on the C
file and then the other are going to do
one
so keeping two Rooks on the board is
very important if black is going to try
to play for a win because with two Rooks
they're more way more ideas for
um for check for mate mating net and
things like that
um someone was asking us about the
schedule a lot of people are asking the
schedule so yes next round will be at 5
00 PM uh around
um so all the odd number rounds are
start at 11 A.M and even at 5 PM we are
only going oh we're only doing
commentary for the morning rounds at 11
A.M Central Time
um but the broadcast will still be on
the chest of you guys uh you want to
um
to check out the games you can certainly
do so we have uh 10 games that are being
broadcasted live
from the super Swiss event yeah I think
this position's pretty safe for white
here at this point
um
I mean Black's going to try and get the
G3 Pawn so I I guess this is what black
wants to do
you know
if black manages to get one of those
pawns it's definitely winning I think
maybe I'm wrong
um because now she went she went back
with the Rook
she was just worried potentially about
some kind of mating net but yeah I'm
surprised she didn't double on the
seventh Rank and try and force one of
the Rooks off the board
because if she would have played um Rook
at age six to H7
she would have okay I think something
similar is happening I'll give check and
then B6 the skin goes there and then
black is entering so she has to find it
I don't think it's as easy for white I
think white has to play very cautiously
this position because
these pawns are very weak whereas black
can get this kind of Pawn structure with
only one weakness if if black Keeps The
Rook on C5 to keep that pawn protected
and then yeah but I think I think maybe
she's fourth it didn't likely G4 later
yeah he did he did end up playing G4 a
little strange
I think he was worried about Rook F5
because if you give this check
ing B1 I think Rook Rook here is gonna
happen you cannot just sit with the
Rooks to avoid the capturing of your
Pawn so I think you probably wanted us
to stabilize those pawns and he might
try something with the Rook on third
Rank and grabbing that pawn right but
after Rook G4 can't I put my Rook on F4
uh which Rook this one no I don't want
to put the back rank one there that one
and then but then she's coming he's
coming check check black can get on a
second rank as well so if you're not
careful but I guess King B1 and now yeah
my ideas have Rook D2 no I want to
reduce three first
to make you take and now Rook D2 I could
be totally but then can't I play Rook
two c one or C4 let's see one
how do we assess this actually I don't
need to trade
and then I can another Rook to C4
oh I see and then I'm guarding my
but but maybe you're right that maybe
going to C4 was more accurate because
maybe you could take on C1 and then take
the A2 pawn and that might be difficult
to draw because you have three but now
you get Rook C2 Rook C2 and I cannot
even do this
so instead of playing after Brook C1
maybe you can take and take the A2 Pawn
yeah this is certainly the first one I'm
capturing yeah I I think that this is
more dangerous this is because black
needs to trade that pawn and then with
these two pawns if you met if right now
connected passers potentially here so
maybe your idea of Rook C4 is more
accurate instead of Rook C1
so if we go back a couple moves
here to play Rook C4 here
I mean it's still still have three weak
Pawns
because Rook takes and I have to take
because if I move my Rook you do have
Rook cm1 right now so I don't have time
to get him seven second rank
so I think I have to take and the
question is what is happening I I mean I
think I should take that Palm Maybe not
maybe I could yeah I think I should take
it yeah and this is highly unpleasant
for white
it is because I'm just bringing my king
might be lost
white is struggling a lot with uh with
being cut on the back Rank and you can't
yeah so yeah let's go back a little bit
further
it's I think it's it's very very
difficult to play this position Rook C
Rook C5
okay so the position is here this is
this is the current position
um
so G4 was played
and he's trying to get Rook C5 and Rook
D2 in my opinion here you cannot really
get on this other side of the board
which should be ideal if white could
somehow get their King on this uh side
of the board then what if we play King
to B1 here
with the idea of you're going to bring
your Rook down I'm going to play Rook C1
and hit C7 with Tempo and that's going
to allow me to um no but I could see
that but now I can play
Rook to see one and you don't have this
option of you know taking and then
taking the A2 oh okay that makes sense
so you know King B1 is one of these
prophylactic moves where you know the
threat was to check but you move away
from the check before it happens
and you're saying that black winds upon
and I would probably manage to somehow
Swindle this with black and wind somehow
I think yeah I've won these kind of
positions before I okay so so we don't
have to trade pot Rooks so we play you
could place your Rook one of the Rooks
on second Rank and try to avoid giving
that but then it's going to be kind of
hard to defend this Pawn I'm thinking
maybe we could go
um but still white would end up messing
up the pawn structure this move seems
hard oh what about Rook here
at least this way this way if you trade
then we take back you do something but
you could play Rook to C3 first instead
of trading is black so after Rook f8
Rook C3
okay so we need to find slightly better
approach
yeah this reminds me of the type of
games that I'm playing in my tournaments
now where I get into these types of
positions is white with no time on my
clock and I'm hopelessly bad at
defending them without no time but
um we should try and find another game
here but hopefully this is a good
illustration on the problems that white
faces in this position even though
they're probably not insoluble I'm just
curious as to what the computer
evaluation is at this ending let's check
in the final position here minus one oh
so my so it is a significant Advantage
so the fact that we can't find an easy
defense for why it is um indicative of
what's really happening
yeah King B1 King B1 was certainly is
certainly a move that it suggests
um
and uh yeah it okay so when it says just
such a small minus in an end game
probably means that it's going to be
pretty pretty balanced probably draw
um with the play but but you don't know
yeah I mean this is one of those things
where I think white is down to finding a
lot of really difficult moves and as the
time ticks down practically this is very
hard to hold for white and she's a very
talented player and if she holds this I
think that's a testament to how talented
she is because you know
Iran's a very good player and um
that's a tough position to hold I agree
let's go to another game we haven't
looked at this is the Nicholas theodoro
game against
um Anna Maria who I I don't know her
I think she's going to school end of
Webster if I'm not mistaken
um I think she's going to that universe
but I'm not 100 sure I probably have met
her I just didn't place a name with the
person and I apologize to her but this
looks like it's winning for white but
because it's close to win I just thought
we could flip through the game because
yeah yeah we're now I think we can look
at the current positions to kind of have
an idea what is going on the plate the
games could have potentially finished
already or could still be underway
because we have the 30-minute delay and
we're still waiting on a potential
interview which we haven't been told
anything about just yet
so H5 was just played so she's trying to
get some some trading here but this end
game you know this is a little bit too
late for that move I think
this should be a win for white yeah two
extra pawns uh and uh Malika Maria
against antipo of Mikhail
this is the current position in their
game it seems like maybe it was a Banco
Pawn structure looks like a Banco or
some kind of
could be totally wrong
oh it was a sicilian no no oh that was
something I would not I based on the
fact that black was missing the E7 Pawn
so I guess maruti and then at some point
um some Knight D5 was played probably
and somehow black ended up losing the
losing the e-pawn so to kind of take you
through the game Knight D5 okay this is
typical so what
what is going on in this position
after quintix Z2 it's not possible to
take
I'm just asking I thought this wasn't
am I missing something
typically I would think that black just
lost a pawn there I mean yeah the
night's not trapped yeah that's what I'm
saying like uh there's no loose pieces
to look at here now
maybe this is Theory maybe this is some
kind of theory that is known as it takes
a knight takes deep yeah yes and then
you have another hanging okay so I guess
you are getting the pump back okay so
this is this is just another line okay I
panicked there for a second that um All
My Life
um whenever I played the maruti we did
the colors I had to my dad made sure
that I knew that idea and I still fell
for it a few times more like in Blitz
Games but still
so um here because of the placement of
the bishop it seems like um you know the
e-file black has to take his Pawn back
this Pawn structure I I know that's
supposed to be much better for white and
plus white has the bishop pair
um do you prefer do you play this with
any colors
I I don't play it
um one of the things that made a lasting
impression on me was you know one of the
players that lives here in St Louis
Lanier Dominguez he went to the World
Cup a couple years ago and he was
playing someone who specialized in the
accelerated dragon and thought okay here
we're going to watch a world-class
player show us how to you know beat the
accelerated dragon and Lanier lost that
match to that guy because the guy
understood the accelerated Dragon better
than him I see and it was a shocking
upset to me and the people that know how
to play these positions is black they
tend to know them really well and
the computer again will say that you're
better in every position is white until
you're not
that's true that is true
um so what is going on here so King H1
and black chose not to take that pawn
here in a tube possibly because of Rook
B4
and then white tree captures it and
suddenly white is a pawn up
so he ended up playing Rook C1 so it's
opposite color Bishops oh G3 I'm not so
sure I'm super fond of that move
yeah but there's a a problem on the back
crank there for white too yeah
what to do indeed what to do with white
in this position
would this be an option and maybe roxy8
you have an extra Pawn but you have to
suffer a little bit right so what
exactly is black stretch well Black's
idea I think isn't it to get the pawn to
A3 and then the
in the garden now you can't right now no
I'm thinking if if we played this move
here
um I guess black could do something like
this and then whenever you take root B8
and try to get Rook B1 oh this is
getting dangerous
very dangerous or maybe not the bishop
here okay because this allows
the king to come to G1 so yeah you could
go to C5 and hit the Rook yeah yeah yeah
my bad I I didn't realize that Nuance
that's an important Nuance we have to
control G1 Square now you take
bam
and if you go uh Bishop E2 of course
I don't know same thing you just write
trade and you win the piece and it's
over that's why she played G3 now we
understand now I understand but or I
understand but uh it's very
uncomfortable these types of positions
um
can come out of the benoni as well or or
Banco oftentimes when you think you're
fine with white but then you push this
Pawn a little bit too soon F3 or F4 and
suddenly you get the bishop here and
when there's still Queens on the board
their ideas with the queen coming in
Bishop back to E5 and suddenly your
entire position is weak yeah I had a
similar position as white with a benko
Gambit but we had a pair of knights on
the board which makes an enormous
difference here because in that position
I played G3 and F3 was weak and and
black got in with you know F5 made that
break but I don't think F5 is going to
be as effective here for black I think
it's about getting the the Rooks in but
but certainly you know even the whites
are pulling up I I don't think that
white has any winning chances here I
think black is pressing because of the
active Rook on C1 the potentially weak
Pawn on A2 and the the back rank
problems
and whites is not threatening to play E5
at any point
I agree and also opposite color Bishops
are
difficult to manage with especially
there is some famous carp of casparov
game with the Queens on the board that
was very very difficult to defend but it
seems that even with Rooks in some
situations you're struggling with uh
with the King and trying to find the
right way to to keep it safe right so
anyways and I mean in a white Bishop on
D4 it's got a safe Square on C5 to go to
it has support squares whereas White's
playing with that Bishop blocked in
behind his pawns so so it has to be
careful with the extra Palm but it's not
easy to come to to you can't say that oh
I'm winning and you definitely need to
keep the Rook on the B file otherwise
you'll arouse yeah and the other thing
too is and sometimes in these King's
Indian positions like if white can trade
his or black can trade his F5 Pawn for
the F3 pawn and then the king can go you
know the G7 F6 E5 and you have a
dominating King position and great you
know White's got an extra Pawn on e4 and
um it's not that easy for white I think
black is pressing here
but I I would be shocked if the game is
still not within the drawing at this
point
so if someone made the comment
and zero one yes yes sir is a very
strong player and Sabina and I are
trying to do our best to explain these
positions without looking at the engine
we both realize that we're not as strong
as some of them or Maurice Ashley I know
we're commenting on it but but that's
okay you guys are
uh yes sir very soon because the
American Cup is starting later this week
so or actually technically next week and
I believe yester is one of the
commentators together with Christian
carilla and Ivanka Huska so stay tuned
for that event we might have in between
the breaks
um some the video promotion for the
American Cup uh one of the strongest
tournaments in the US that you guys
don't want to miss either and if you
miss yes sir he's definitely going to be
there but we appreciate you being here
if you're watching for from YouTube or
twitch so
um hopefully you can stay with us as
well we try our best to give you as much
detail on the position and our thoughts
on what is happening
um you know
um
without using the engine
so hopefully that is appreciated as well
and uh and you guys continue joining us
um right you're seeing two players that
are Master Level players here that are
giving you their their view on the
position and chess is a struggle and I
mean to the extent you're seeing us
struggle with it I mean that's really
part of the process when you're playing
these games that it is a struggle and
you have to find the right ideas and
then play them and it's easy to look at
the computer it's much harder to play in
one of these tournaments and you have no
computer to help you it's of course of
course and there's sometimes pressure on
some of the players whether it's a
closed tournament you U.S Championship
the American Cup or simply an open
tournament any kind of tournament it is
there's often a lot of pressure and
um you know the the players here in this
tournament in the Sandler super Swiss
are playing for 25 for a price fund of
25 000 with the first price being six
thousand dollars it's it's definitely
you know a tough tournament
um we have 10 games live that we are
trying to
um change among if you guys have
preference uh of the game that you want
us to go over please feel free to let us
know we're happy to go over the the game
that you want provided that it's one of
the live games 41 players are playing in
this event so we have 20 boards one
player is Christopher Woo's game again
that's changed a little bit against
Gabriella uh Christopher you okay that
was an interesting game I really I
really oh this is
this is
so black how did the night still stay
there I just sacrificed a couple pawns
here and remember white was going to get
pressure on the C file yeah and then
this was an interesting idea but that
didn't that give some squares gift
squares but you know Gabriella went for
both breaks here she went for F3 so she
created maximum tension in this position
and then she took now I don't know if
she was ready to capture but she had no
choice I take C4 yeah she had no choice
um she had some Choice actually that was
another choice but that wasn't letting
the Knight coming to C4 so it wasn't
like a real real choice
if it were me and if these were my you
know this wasn't the Contour maybe I
would maybe I would sacrifice maybe I
would go Patrician style but I don't
think I have sufficient you'd usually go
for Bishops
um we don't have sufficient uh material
it's a PT because it would be nice right
here
if you could get that pawn it would be
and when I'm sacrificing The Exchange I
always feel more comfortable when I'm
doing it and my Bishop is my mind yeah I
prefer nice I'm I'm the night and the
person who loves Knights I would have
four nights if you would maybe at the
start of the game I'll take them anytime
but no okay I agree it's not
okay
foreign
[Music]
thing
but what exactly
what is exactly is he getting
rookie one okay I'm not a fan of that
move
um is this a real threat
it is so we cannot just go Knight back
to G2 this is our worst place piece so
we need to find a way to improve it
I guess we don't have a way
so we have to go rookie one rookie eight
and now she played E3
okay this move is important because
you would not want to allow either a
knight or a rook to get to E3 after that
uh White would just collapse let's just
play some random move here for right
just to kind of show I think this is
right
am I
uh Night comes here so you cannot allow
this kind of thing I just put the random
move to show the audience you know how
terrible that's that situation is but
here black should still have some ways
to take advantage of that night well
presumably Black's gonna have to play G5
to kick the Knight back because right
now the night guards the F3 entry Square
so you need to get a piece to F3 either
The Rook or the queen is that too much
it's not my Pawn so oh well I think at
this point black is already all in for
doing this because Black's already
sacrificed two pawns so I don't think
it's too much I think it's just what
black is committed to
yeah he has to do it but I think it's
it's the right the right thing to do
Christopher has had some brilliant games
in the Junior and U.S Championship as
well so
um Knight G2 and I think we can just
bring in The Rook
as you said well no no can can white
start trading with Rook F1 or did I just
get the E3 pawn and am I winning
everything
um how do you want to trade can't I take
great takes yeah
um we have to take an F3 right that's
I'm trading one pair of Rooks and then
I'm taking on
E3 and I'm hoping I don't get mated but
after Rook takes and then rookies I
don't think you are I don't
let's see well I don't necessarily need
to take in C7 but I have to because if I
go queen queen D2 there's rookie two
okay I kind of have to and then you are
actually mating me so I got Queen takes
G5 check but Queen takes C7 makes the
most sense because you're bringing your
pieces in well if that's not an option
then this is probably a better
better decision
black would have to play decimal right
but there's no checks after taking on C7
right
so so if I take on C7 what no this is
the move that I wanted to play right but
it's not me wait you have this check
and then this channel
I probably wanted to check on um you
don't I was thinking the queen can go to
H3 later right for a mate
this is this is this is bent this is
winning right
check and game over
but for black
yeah because if you go King G7 I have
this check
and
yeah yeah it's just winning
is it
foreign
you could have checked on D7 instead of
B7 oh I just thought that if I do that
then then the queen can go back okay
white should still be here
about that yeah okay we're really far
we're really far from the game but this
is
um Queen takes C7 I guess I cannot go
here but if I don't go there I don't
really have much Choice yeah yeah we
have to go back I mean we have to go
back G5 is a little bit too soon
I think so Christopher decided to play
Rook F6 instead in this position
this was the choice that that he made
um so Rook F6 and now
what is his idea does he want to play
Rook H6 just like that but just without
weakening his King possibly that's
that's the idea that he wants to to go
for yeah and White's got limited moves
here I mean I'm sitting here looking at
this thinking that maybe Rook to C2 is
the move that White's gonna play here
the only thing I don't like with Rook to
C2 is that you're staying on some kind
of
in the worst case I think black and gold
you know let's just be materialistic
there for like a second maybe I don't
know
maybe not
and what I want to take I I really want
to take the fun
yeah I mean I think this is a position
where black probably has sufficient
compensation for the two Pawns
maybe it's more than that I don't know
and you're right maybe I can just double
the Rooks first although if I double
there maybe I can play E4
um because you know I'm not mated
necessarily but man you're starting to
get scared after you know Rook ef-8
there you are indeed and we are told
that we have the interview with VAR
akobian so stay tuned We're Gonna Roll
It
I am with Grand Master varusian akobian
fresh off of his win against Nicholas
Ladon Bart tell me how you did it and uh
take me through your game and just uh
tell all the people what you did hello
everybody yeah it was a very interesting
game Jacob it was a short game only 19
moves but some interesting ideas there
you know the content was I think
interesting so I open up with B4 E5
Knight C3 and now I play Knight F6 as
soon as the Knight F6 is played we know
he's Queen's Gambit declined opening so
I took
and the bishop G5
okay Bishop before this one is a little
bit surprising typically they play here
C6 is one of the main moves from Bishop
himself and Bishop before he's trying to
transpose into some type of regozen
positions
so
there are many different ways to play
here in Knight F3 but I'd say okay I'll
play it now H6
and here I have to choose Bishop H4 but
then he was going to play G5 Bishop g394
activating and putting some pressure
then some H5 H4 coming up I normally
don't like the Knight only four so I
usually just try to avoid this because
it sometimes you can allow this but you
have to be like super super precise in
theory to make sure you know it works
out but it just gets a lot more
complicated than I like so I just took
we took back and now very important move
Queen name for check because he would
like to put the panel on C6 and then
retreat with the bishop on D6 black has
pair of the Bishops here so in a long
run you know it will be good for him so
that's why I had to play this one check
to force the Knight on C6 on Awkward
Square because now the bishop is hanging
so he played Knight through C6 Knight F3
and now we transpose into just the
dragon in our book C1 normally white
plays the movie Bishop B2 here with the
idea to cancel but I think about book C1
because I would like to have an idea to
capture back when we look on C3 so that
was what I was thinking now it goes here
it should be two
developing and here's I think what Anika
made a mistake here he
analyzed with him for a while so
perfect was the best move here okay
we've done that so and the black is more
or less okay maybe white is slightly
better but what black is trying to
achieve is to play 97 C6
and that's the whole point of playing
Queen A4 because you force the Knight to
a bad position then he has to make
several moves to play the move C6 of
course and now yeah he will play 97 C6
and then try to regroup with 96 Bishop
D6 really slightly better for white but
nothing too special but when you took it
it's a mistake because I came with the
pawn and then I'm gonna play the move C4
immediately and trade the central file
with this one and then have pressure on
the C file so why is slightly better now
play 97 C4 and I think here this queen
G6 Pawn was not so good I think it was a
little bit better for him to play the
same with C6
capture dig back with a knight and uh
play that position white is definitely
slightly better here but he chose to
play the move Queen G6 Castle Bishop HT
it looks kind of you know cool but
actually after the move 91 at some point
I was making H final Bishop has to go
back so I think it was still not too
late to play Maybe C6 except that you
know Whitefish is going to be slightly
better for a long time but here they
play the move C5
and here I thought I feel a really
strong move because he's trying to open
up the center and I realize I have this
stronger Queen a tree what this one does
is he can never take one before because
the Knight is hanging and now I'm
threatening to take the pawn on C5 and
in often times in this positions also if
cake occurs I can take back and suddenly
my queen is attacking the H3 Bishop so
overall a great move now I'm at least
winning the pawn
and uh he took yeah very sneaky idea
yeah it's very it's it's one of those
moves it's easy to miss he missed it
it's like a quiet move but very strong
you know so once again the idea is just
extreme the night and trying to win up
on you so he took
expect now hitting the knife and now it
fake
Knight F5
1995 is another possibility but I can
play group xc4 winning upon
and I think in each one tonight there's
okay saving and here specifically E3
Rook ac8 perhaps was not the best move
um
Bishop G4
was the best you can play with people in
this position so
my plan was to play
here
yeah
but but he actually went here and after
but okay he actually didn't have as much
time here
and uh he just you know spent a little
bit more time but here about 10 minutes
left we usually resigned here which was
a little bit surprising but the whole
point is he's losing a piece yeah okay
and if it was Bishop before F3 G4 yeah
he's protecting the three
three four so overall uh Goods Good
Start you know
I think I played you know some some some
good moves in you know Queen A3 in
particular I like and um so yeah happy
with the start here so yeah obviously a
good way to start off the tournament we
have one point gonna go into the next
round very very convincingly thank you
so much for coming in it was always
lovely having you thank you thank you
Drake Thank you guys see you next time
well that was a nice uh interview uh
with VAR taking us through the game I
hope you guys enjoyed it that was that
was cool uh we'll have more of those so
if you guys have someone in particular
you would like us to try to get after
the game don't forget they do play
another game in the afternoon so you
know we're we're thankful if they choose
to give us a little bit of time so that
everyone gets the chance to hear their
thoughts on how the game went
um so far we had VAR we'll see if anyone
else will be interviewed a little bit
later
um
Perez's game on board six against women
International master I think it's still
a jackler I think because I know the C
is J in Turkey Turkey but I could be
wrong I I don't know her
I think she's going to discover I don't
know to which university she's going I
could be wrong I could be very much
wrong but this is an interesting
position here
whites upon down but you know he has
some pressure on the king side it's
probably winning for black but um
you think for black is running for Block
why
well I'm assuming you know that Rook is
going to come to A2 and that that past a
pawn is going to be strong but
it's an interesting position there's
threats of you know 95 Knight G6 check
in some lines this is this is unpleasant
as well I actually was thinking about
this move right now
um
maybe it doesn't do anything
I guess you have a check and where do we
go
what if what if white chooses to trade
that Rook off just say
your Rook is bothering I guess you could
take and then go A5 right
yeah and then I don't have my attacking
potential on the king side yeah it's
actually interesting that he chose to go
King h8 this is nice so he's not in a
rush to take that pawn this happens
sometimes when you're being attacked
with Queens on the board too using that
pawn as a shield to protect the king to
avoid uh mates or things like that and
here of course there are checks that
would be annoying
um maybe even I think if black took just
to kind of show the audience probably
Rook somewhere
um I'm not sure exactly where and then
this mate might be unstoppable
or maybe you have Rook F6 no but that
doesn't help
so that's it just came over right when
we looked at when I was looking in this
position just before you brought up in
the screen and and the pawn was on G6
and black played Bishop E7 which was an
interesting move and now
it looks like black has this under
control because of the weakness of you
know the F2 pawn and the Knight on C4
so maybe this is just winning for black
the only thing I don't like at the
moment for black in Black's position is
this rookine A4 which I understand it
will go to A2 and it will be very
unpleasant but until then I have a move
the question is can I do something with
this extra move one or two moves if I
could do something of course
um that would be great I don't know if I
have time to double up so let's just
test this Theory out with maybe Rook G4
anyways
and when you go here I want to go Rook
G1 so my thread would be just that check
and then at least having some Perpetual
check if not more
and that's why I was a little bit
confused when you said you know it's
you're right that's a big threat there
so I'm
so Rook to G4
and maybe Rook F7 the point but no I
still go yeah it's um
it's actually scary for black
a little bit no yeah no it definitely is
if you understand that you need to
utilize that pawn as as an attacking
tool and not go back into the mindset
that oh this is an end game and I'm not
doing so well my opponent is coming here
pushing the pawn I gotta do something
about that if you try to utilize this
idea it could be it could be creating
dangers for for black in the position I
know someone was asking so the playing
location is not at the club for this
tournament do you actually know I don't
know it's at a former church that's a
building part of St Louis University
that's probably about two miles from
here that they're playing
so they're they're um they're recording
the video that you saw with VAR was
coming from there so they are not
playing
um they're not playing in the chess club
at the moment so that's what's happening
and someone's mentioning in the position
that a my mic volume needs to go up I'm
going to need help from our technician
with that I can't control that from here
and that Rook takes F3 is an idea and
and that was exactly my point when I
thought this was potentially winning for
black is that after Rook to A2 Rook
takes F3 threatens to win a piece but to
sabina's point if white plays The Rook
to G1 first yeah there's these potential
mating threats here so so I don't know
if you can do anything about this
situation after Rook G1 like
um if you where do you move the Rook
could you go
could you just go back in F7 and
right but you can't
so
we're saying Rook G4 Rook takes F3 I
mean technically I could just go Rook G3
maybe I was just right right play Rook
cheese I should just play Rook G3 oh
Rook G3 was played huh right right but
my my comment or my thought was after
Rook A2 you're also threatening Rook
takes F3 in some of these lines too
because of the the pin but now you've
got this issue okay Rook check King
takes this is mate and that's mate so
that's the end of the world for you
right right as I said for black I mean
this would be a
juggler problems I'm pronouncing her
name correctly if there's anyone from
Turkey here let us know right yeah I
mean when I went to this position I mean
I initially made the comment that I
thought black was going to be winning
but I also thought the position looked
interesting too which is why I suggested
we bring the game up and you know this
is one of those positions where they
call it a critical moment and a critical
moment in a chess game is where the
value of the move is going to change the
outcome by a half point or more so at
this point white and black are really
have to make very precise moves here or
they could turn the position into either
a draw that's a wind form or a loss that
would be either a draw or wind farm so
these are very very critical moves and I
don't know how much time the players
have left at this point six minutes for
for Sila 14 minutes for for
um
so I'm not sure oh he played Bishop D6
so he's really trying to get this move
in he's thinking that would work that's
why I wanted Rook G4 but maybe my line
was
um a little bit offbeat there for a
second but
we can have the exact same idea now
right
um
and uh if I want to be even more fancy I
don't want to be more fancy as I was
going to say that I could go there but
um Rook G4 I would play
I'm not scared
maybe I should be but I'm not
so what is happening in this position do
you have more
okay I sacrificed the piece and I have a
threat of mating too radiator of G7
and
so you have Rook I don't have seven is
the only thing that I can think of to
defend right
but again how do you plan on doing
how do you plan on defending after this
it's just maybe maybe yeah there's
Bishop f8 is there so if you go to G4
okay let's just let's just be let's just
be kind to the position not drop
anything the mate is the mate is both H4
and H1 each one is going to be in two
moves
so what's what's black going to do to
stop that
King back draw
I mean I don't know I'm not seeing it
I'm not saying anything
um obviously I can turn on the engine
but I don't want to
so now someone is suggesting Knight
takes D2 after rook bg1 in the
commentary but the Knight on F3 guards
the uh the the D2 Bishop so if we go
back here you put they're suggesting
Knight takes D2 but
but I I mean I want to do to have a draw
I don't want to win right she's saying
that I'm not I'm not having a draw
I was playing this whole line because I
thought I had to draw
okay so you're saying you you think you
can escape if you come with the King up
here but you know what happens when you
have two Rooks right one goes up one
goes down and you can't stop both
right and there's no checks there's this
one if you want to sacrifice The Rook
maybe that does something
takes takes okay I still want two mates
you have one more check I'll give you
that okay
no more chicks now and
there's an ig3 okay someone can say look
I have a defense okay you got the
defense
yeah you got some defense going no that
that looks fairly effective
okay maybe I was being too too kind
I was being too kind I can also just go
King F3
but Knight G3 is still enough yeah yeah
because if you trade you've got a
winning rook and pawn ending okay should
I give one more check then
I could give a couple more checks here
now I'm not sorry sorry I'm sorry I
meant King here he uh black has to play
King here
but no now the bishop can you can go to
G5 with the Rook on
um G4
but now if a rook takes F2 check 94
check it's The Rook yeah that doesn't
work Rook G1
does he have the same thing again
this annoying idea no because now we
have King here and if Knight G3 we got
made because we attracted the king all
the way to lower
you don't escape you don't skip that
easily we're not letting you escape
I can see some of you guys are excited
about escaping but nope
it's not happening
okay basically what we want with white
okay we're not gonna win we will have a
draw yes okay uh we have this drawing
idea maybe it's an interesting position
here
yeah I believe I have to do this because
so in the game black played Rook takes
F3 so they're passed there now really on
my board here they're now past where we
were really
yeah I can see that
that date
okay let's go back
I still see this position after Bishop
D6 okay yeah so they played
um Rook to G8
I don't know why oh God it's refresh
and just give me one moment nope I still
don't have the new moves okay well why
don't we switch over to Christopher use
game again here because he's made some
process for you and I think there's a
result there's a result in the game the
Nicolas teodoro won against Mariano
Maria we had seen the towards the end of
that game after age five I think this
was the that game yeah so not much
longer the game ended uh we'll see if we
can get
um Nicholas on an interview potentially
um and then uh okay Alice lost so let's
let's see what happened in that end game
was a very interesting end game oh she
ended up blundering right after right
after we left off at least and this is
where I had suggested King to be one
yeah that was a really nice idea which
is one of these um prophylactic moves
because the threat is Rook to C5 for
black and sometimes a technique in
calculation is is that if your opponent
has a threat and you're going to have to
play a defensive move is you play the
defensive move first which then gives
you another option on the next move
right and it's hard sometimes to get
yourself to think that way but
apparently that may have been close to
the only move in this position for white
and and I you know even though I saw it
when we were analyzing here I can't sit
here and tell you how to seen it if I
was playing the game
it was a tough move it's not the kind of
move that you want to make
if you are getting the king away from
the center away from the side of the
board but you are avoiding
um checks and you're getting ready to
attack the pawn later without allowing
black and this is very this would have
been an important move
at least I ever ended up playing Rook 7
to F4 which is bad from the point of
view that it leaves that seat seven Pawn
unattacked anymore so she doesn't have
these kind of ideas she probably wanted
to go for that pawn but after Rook D2
now King B1
but now black was able to capture this
Pawn without suffering the attack on the
C7 Pawn so when The Rook was there there
were these kind of ideas right yeah
white lost his counter her counter play
in this case and yes you get the G4
opponent once Black's doubled on the
second rank your your helpless here is
white yeah she probably found she
thought she can defend like this but
this rook in A4 is very tough
to deal with unfortunately and after
King B7 G4
probably haruk ended up being stuck yeah
look at that B5
this is very sad this is this is a very
sad joke you want your Rooks to be open
attack and and she went with the Rook
from F7 to A3 she probably realized as
soon as she brought her Rook back here
that it's gonna be tough but there's
nothing else that you can do at this
point and
um
there's that so I think someone said
Christopher you is on the verge of
winning so I'd like to go back to that
game he won okay he won
we didn't see the end of that game
though so after that what happened
um let's just
put the end there
um
okay so she was never able to get the
Rook out and then
okay
okay yeah The Rook strap okay
and and hopefully we'll get an interview
with some of the winners here shortly
I'm not sure if we can get a ROM on or
if we can get Christopher you on as an
interview I think either one of those
players would be very good to get on at
this point
yeah I think uh yeah if we still have
time I think they play in two hours so
they might right they might go grab some
something
before their next round we're being told
that they're looking for both of those
players but again because it is two
rounds a day and these players need to
play beginning in an hour and five
minutes they're probably trying to get
something to eat you got to get a little
bit of rest in so it might be difficult
to get any further players for
interviews at this point in time but
we're going to see what we can do yes
so Rook F3 was played so it seems like
in the end he ended up going for that G5
move so after Rook F6 this was just a
nice preparation kind of move waiting to
see what white is going to do because
there was It was kind of hard yeah and
it's interesting I'm looking at the
valuation the computer here that after
G5 it says zero zero zero and after the
move I suggested Rook C2 it gives a big
fat question mark and essentially
White's lost but this is
does if we actually
did Rook C2 yeah Rook C2 it goes down to
1.2 and the only move is Queen to C2 F1
or Rook F1 might be another move that
makes sense here okay we're not gonna
look at that engine right now so it's
it's a rook C2
but you know these are the kind of
positions where white is two pawns up
and literally white is playing for a
draw here the the moves are hard to find
for white in this position and to me
Rook to C2 looked like a logical move
looking at it without the engine and it
literally is a losing move
it's because
look away from potentially having the
opportunity to trade roads black is
attacking so you have to find defensive
mechanisms by trading pieces and then
Rook F1 seems like the right thing to do
as well Queen C2 I don't know exactly
what is the purpose of this move maybe
try to get something like this in or
maybe even E4 support the push of E4 and
just say I don't think you can do
something on the f file I'm going to try
to get some you know I have a passport
let's try to push it yeah yeah I mean
the computer is giving a crazy line here
I can see it after you know Queen C2
rookie f8 E4 and H5 and you know this
seems crazy to me that White's allowed
to push you know a pass Pawn on E5 and
and potentially is it's just zero zero
zero according to computer but of course
if you are playing this position in a
game you would have no idea what the
evaluation is right
right and this this moves this move I'm
not even sure if that if it's the kind
of move that you want to make although
your trading pieces this night is
technically not attacking so why would
you be thinking to trade it but but
Knights are notoriously horrible
Defenders on the fiancado square
that is true
but also
also chairman I
mean a few Grandmasters use it including
Grandma Sarah moradia body he uses This
this term with Superfluous Square I love
that I love that term I think he loves
it more than me uh but but like when you
have a square that you want to utilize
for multiple pieces
um and then the queen is actually better
placed there because it keeps the king a
little bit more like more protected like
you said in the night is not doing such
a great job so you want to do that so
that you can finally use the square for
the queen
yeah I I mean I find this kind of stuff
fascinating that in the computer world
it's zero zero zero but when you're
sitting behind the board trying to play
this position it's awful you're probably
used to you were telling me you were
telling me in the break that uh well
also live I think you you mentioned that
you're also playing correspondence chess
and you're probably used to analyzing
with engines a lot to prepare for your
various lines that you're playing well I
I do and I also trained for over the
board someone's mentioning here about
Doug bringing the knowledge and homework
club and what he's referring to is is we
both belong to Jakob ogard's Academy
killer chess training and he does weekly
homework with hard problems and so I I
try and analyze without an engine but
certainly in correspondence just it's
competitive research where you're using
an engine but you're trying to look
extraordinarily deeply into the position
yeah and I I don't play very much
anymore because it's just a draw chess
and stockfish 15 was an enormous
increase in the strength of the engines
yes and and really when you went from 14
to 15 it was probably 100 to 150 Point
increase in strength but it changed the
evaluation of a lot of positions that
people thought were maybe better and now
it moved into a draw oh wow so it
increased the the drawing capabilities
and positions
so let's see here we have the safe
is down a piece for two pawns against
Evan Park on board three which is an
interesting position
four two or three I believe there are
Bailey of yeah yep the thief and
um
I mean this would be a an enormous upset
of Evan one I mean vasif is an
extraordinarily strong Grand Master he
um went through I believe to at least
the final 16 and maybe the quarterfinals
of the World Cup a couple years ago when
he won a couple major tournaments in
Europe so he he's an extremely strong
player
and
um
this is just I
he's also a fighter I'm surprised he
doesn't take a draw here but this is the
thief who I I just went back to see how
they got into that position with a with
the piece down right but Evan's the one
who actually avoided the draw yeah but
uh but like why did he why did he allow
for this I was just trying to go back a
few moves he just stayed pinned there he
doesn't have a way to escape couldn't he
have played
King G2 for example no because he loses
no he could have
he could have right I I think so
um it doesn't do anything we just trade
okay we're good
right well yeah we trade and the King
should be able to come over it seems
like it yeah
yeah I'm surprised about this move I
wonder if he somehow missed this idea
or
I didn't know what to say so okay so
Evan Parker is going for the win now and
this is a good example of a young player
that's playing Fighting Chess against a
very very strong Grand Master and is
going for a win here
my gut reaction to this position is that
it's a draw
um well it's a it's a wrong Corner wrong
color Square yeah
so
but there's still a g Pawn on the board
and you haven't been able to trade it
yet as long as that pawn is still there
black should be winning
even if it's wrong Corner Bishop
where
right well I mean White's got three
pawns you know two two extra pawns with
F4 and the E Pawn to play F4 F5 my F3 G4
and then I would have to take then you
take back then you have to go here and
then H5 in order to be able to make a
draw so or or I can go for F4 F5 if I
can get it in
I was saying if the queens were to be
traded here oh oh did he go for a queen
trade no he did not he play Queen C3
yeah I don't think white can afford to
trade Queens I think white needs to have
the Queens on the board but but that's
the thing why just play it here why
that's what I'm saying oh is this is
this winning for black that's what I was
trying to figure out because I don't
think you managed to to trade
so let's see so like now we can go
Bishop
f8 and then I was saying that I was
saying that this is the way to trade
mm-hmm but I want to play here
so you'll have to protect
or maybe not maybe we don't care about
that point
we cannot play G4 no you trade and it's
over
this is waiting for black because we're
controlled but even if you put the King
on H3 okay I'm just gonna bring my King
around is black well that's what I'm
saying do we have time because uh White
wants to play here you have to take
right I have to take
and and now I'm saying that oh wait I
can even I can do this oh that's it yeah
everything takes yeah I thought I had to
take this
um and then go G5 and then H right but
King takes is the right movement yeah so
it should be a draw okay so but no you
know what they but but white took with
the F Pawn they've got this position on
the board here and instead of playing
King takes which we were saying looks
like a draw white took with the F Pawn
if that's not my analysis that you're
saying can you just click on it because
I feel sometimes you're just getting my
analysis oh maybe I am I think that's
right that's why you are seeing all
those moves extra okay my apologies
no no I because I was wondering why
you're getting that but usually they
don't stay the analysis but somehow they
sustain but this is on your computer I
know no I don't know why you got those
moves but um unless that that happened
unless it's possible that it happened
but then you clicked on it yeah
okay that's something different now all
right all right we fixed so we figured
that out at the list we know that there
are no extra moves so the Casada
position has simplified dramatically
Casada Perez on board six let's let's
check that
did they play what we suggested no
she did not she gave up the exchange I
really want to check that line I'm sorry
guys
I just want to know I was right that was
good that dead draw after production
before I still can I still can come oh
but look at this move that we missed
Rook H1
you're not as excited as I am oh it's
fantastic yeah yeah
uh and again this gets to my comment
about critical moments so so we're going
on this line and this was this is draw
this is draw like we were saying right
here here check here
we were right about this this this this
this
oh so he is giving just checks with the
rook and those perpetual
[Music]
but look at this one so you see no
wonder they tell you I don't know who
who is the first person who is saying
this one move forward two moves back or
something like that I've seen it in some
commentary
um someone was saying this or one of the
big guys commentary guys
um and then
you know we went on that line so long
that we forgot to go back and see that
Rook of three bam yeah this is so
gorgeous that's an incredibly difficult
move to say I know I feel like this is
gonna this thing is gonna go because
you're talking about Jacob he's gonna go
in his killer training well sure and I
mean I'm sitting there looking at that
move trying to figure out okay if I was
given this position in saying it was
white to play and win a would I find
that move at all and B how long would it
take me to find that but that's why they
never tell you what is happening they
just tell you why to move play right
they don't really tell you right what to
do they shouldn't tell you what to do I
think
it makes it too easy because when we
play we never have the
you know right no we never do but I'm
just saying it's a really difficult move
to find even if you know it's white to
play and win it's really beautiful
because the whole point is that it's
combining all of the that we saw
previously so not just the G file I'm
trying to mate but when you go back look
at Faith this idea with Bishop H6 going
to Bishop G7 so you're literally taking
advantage of that King being so weak and
you know this check does nothing because
you go King D3 and the bishop still
controls the two square I guess you can
still play the move but then you know
we'll have an in exchange up and and
this this position is just brilliant
yeah that's an amazing position so where
are they at currently now so they stop
the engine now because that was at least
we were right so she ended up going
Knight H4
uh Sila and then okay she gave up the
exchange to get it back over there but
was this good enough
uh I don't know okay two I really like
Black's move here I think the other
option was potentially this which I'm
not sure if it would have worked or not
maybe
uh maybe white would have the option to
at some point maybe now or at some point
have the smooth Knight C5 and
take something back right maybe takes
all right you're hitting the Rook on B1
that's an important detail check first
right
and um
probably White
could have
sufficient actually you have to go here
and then I'm I'm planning this check
although you could you couldn't come
here
yeah I mean you could check but Black's
got a check on e4 that you're stopping
but
you go to E3 like if I come here what's
what's happening I'm pretty happy with
this rook and pawn ending is black I
think
black should be happy with the sun game
I think so I I mean I'm not saying it's
winning but I'm saying it's really hard
to draw as well I'm not sure how we take
back possibly upon
I love broken games but I I'm a little
bit stumbled here as to which piece to
take but probably Pawn Yeah the pond
fixes that weakness on C3 but it's it's
hard to get the king in there and the
rook's a little bit stuck
there's an argument that what you want
to do here is take with the Rook because
it leaves you with the option of the B4
break to maybe weaken both pawns and you
might win the D4 pawn and leave yourself
with the E5 Pawn
but E5 typically can get Philadelphia
yeah well I'm saying if you can win both
of them for the big fun and it's not
easy I I would guess this is a draw but
again it's one of these positions that's
practically hard to defend I agree
so the game continued okay two
did not uh uh sorry he he did not take
an F2 now Rook G1 was played but then he
didn't get the oh
okay
he doesn't have the chance to take the
F2 Pawn okay that's even better for
white because we still have this Pawn
so Bishop takes F2 seems like it should
have been played no yes yeah yeah it
seems like there was a Miss there
uh because even now if you go Knight C5
we just we just go to K2 now and
okay I guess you have some chairs no you
cannot because I'll I'll come here and
it's with temple
so I think that was a Miss they're both
getting low on time or maybe he was
trying to catch her because she doesn't
have much time
but then he didn't and they reached wait
there's no second time there's no
secondary time control that's why I said
with this game 90 plus 30 seconds
which in my view is really the correct
time control all the players are down to
their increment essentially now and they
have to play the rest of the game this
way so there's going to be a lot of
mistakes and you know these types of
games it's really like taking a college
exam where you have to give an answer
every 30 seconds and your penalty for
getting one wrong is that you lose
and heaven knows how many games I've
lost in these situations in these
tournaments someone may have noticed
that my ratings extremely low if you
would see the games there's a consistent
pattern as I I get older that I I have
very good positions that I I make
slightly worse and then I get into these
mad time scrambles and I lose almost
every one of them and it's very painful
it is it's tough it's tough to play with
uh with just one time control in my
opinion but
but even two It's tricky because you
sometimes spend a little bit too much
because you know
you have a second time control and then
um because you spend so much time
um you could you could be you know
getting low to
right like really though close to 40 and
then end up
I think for Zone has won two that was an
interesting game from the perspective
that it had the hanging pawns so maybe
that age six we never went back to that
game yeah if we if we could just look to
see how
um you know Lazaro exploited the hanging
pawns because I think there were some
questions about that yeah we stopped
around here
in that game and then
and then we took in C5 took 93
and this is a Classic Plan here where
white piles up on the uh the hanging
ponds
and tries to attract black to push one
of the pawns and then it's gonna block
them so for example if if he gets you to
play here it's gonna block this Pawn
this Pawn will stay weak forever and
then switch over to attack that pawn the
same thing would happen if you would
push this Pawn at some point then this
other one will stay weak we'll try to
block it at least in theory and practice
is always so much more difficult
I got hanging pawns on many occasions
with both
I was playing both with the pawns or
without and
you know I had I had mixed they're
interesting positions to play and you
know dynamically the hanging pawns can
produce some very nice answers but when
white has the bishop on G2 because
normally black is playing for an attack
but when white has the bishop in a fee
and cattle position like this it's
almost impossible for black to generate
an attack against the white king and I
think practically these positions are a
little bit harder for black than say if
the white Bishop was on E2 or D3 like it
often can be in say some of the
semi-slav lines where these positions
arise but with the bishop already on G2
I think this is a much more favorable
configuration for white
I
I that hidden he understands here he
didn't even need to put a lot of
pressure he just pushed E4 yeah this is
the famous Fisher maneuver from game six
where if black takes on e4 he's left for
the perpetually weak Pawn on C5
and it which he's probably going to just
simply lose immediately in this position
and if he plays D4 like he did in the
game
you know he he's
in a position where his pawns aren't
going anywhere and white can just expand
I mean if these Knights could kind of
switch places that would be nice I don't
think that's happened in the game okay
he just went for the bishop
and then
if I were right I would try some Palm
pushes but I guess he has to to be on
the look for potentially this move
oh so he just he just won tactically he
just went with a small tactic here he
did yeah and that's partly why these
positions are so hard to play is is
because it white has lots of small
tactics like this and it's very easy for
black to fall into them so you have to
be extremely aware on every move
and I think
I think
that happened looks like we got already
some so we already knew Liang won his
game against the Josiah stiermann and
then
um Irene Drew against darus reards
remember we had we had seen that
interesting G6 this is an interesting
idea in this Kalashnikov Sicilian that
you're mentioning you're not familiar
with this move in this position and uh
let's see if he ever got Bishop H6 I
guess not
I guess you did not but he got his
Knight on on D4 I forgot about that idea
um this is actually much better much
better than than the typical
um nidor for svishnikov positions where
where where you're getting that Outpost
because the pawn is on C3 in those
positions so you're controlling but now
he didn't so that was his idea yeah now
now we understand right after white
didn't have pressure on D6 right you
plunked the Knight on D4 and it's very
hard to deal with there yeah and and
to get this other night
you start to protect protect War for now
so you don't have the time to CH to to
play Knight C2
I think right so that's why and now you
know whenever you go Knight C2 he can
get this other Knight to I don't know if
he did that but no he didn't he took
okay
maybe he kept the night for a potential
F5
yeah I don't know that black ever wants
to play F5 in these positions because it
weakens the it opens the bishop up on G2
and you don't really have an attack
so then why didn't he go here
yeah I guess he doesn't he didn't want
to keep his night he was more focused on
on getting B5 right he got in B5 hoping
to you know sort of pin the two pawns
down for one on the queen side and
eventually get in D5
but then after the capture everything
traded off
um white probably still found a way to
get her Knight onto D5 there she was
there it was and then this position is
actually very interesting to me because
um on the one hand this Pawn is blocking
or or has stabilized the structure for
white in a way it's going to be hard to
push A3 right because B3 is going to be
weak pass one but weak but
um but also white has a little bit more
space and if somehow The Rook would get
to C4 this Pawn would be weak
um but
oh she played A3 great I should look at
the moves before no no no no no it's a
reasonable comment because it is
weakening the pawn there but there's an
offsetting weakness on T6 technically it
worked right okay so it's it and it's
also a little interesting
A3 instead of A4
I agree
but I guess she thought he had no other
choice but to trade
well yeah but you're giving black a
choice if you play it yeah
you know and giving players a choice
especially in single time control
tournaments is a strategy because you're
forcing them to to take time now maybe
he just takes right away anyway that was
her strategy to make
is should I take should I stay and maybe
he spend some time here actually do we
have the time to say
yeah look at that he spent 10 minutes
okay so if all would have been in A4 he
would have probably made the move
instantaneous oh we don't know we don't
know we don't know we'll find out one
day
okay so
um and they give Bishop takes a question
mark which is surprising but yeah and
what the engine was saying Rook takes
was a better was a better decision which
is interesting because I thought the
bishop was supposed to go there
maybe there's E4
right but interestingly here the
computer thinks that black is already a
little bit better here and I think it
gets to your point there's a weakness on
B3 and black can expand on the king's
side you know yeah he can now he
actually can at his leisure so you know
if you're black in this kind of position
you're playing a low rated lower rated
player albeit a very strong lower rated
player and you've created an imbalance
in The Possession so normally you
wouldn't want to treat pieces I'm
actually surprised he he went for Rook
say C1 because you wouldn't want to
trade I would have thought that he would
play Rook to B8 here which pressures the
the B3 Pawn C6 an option or no
I'm just no no
not just it's an idea
um I don't think it's working
um because this this is writing right
you have to be able to connect the pawns
up
it's not an option
maybe just Ruby one
yeah but then yeah yeah I agree I I
don't think the trade was was necessary
but you're playing and as a higher rated
player it's a little surprising to see
him trade the Rooks here
because you're combining sort of the
possibility of F5 E4 f4 on the king side
with you know keeping pressure on the
b-pawn
and you removed one of the pressure
points so now you can't attack sort of
both sides of the board you're limited
to one side with one Rook
looks like pretty much every single game
has finished we we um
we were not told if we have another
interview
coming up probably not
no more everybody has a game within the
next 40 minutes and so we've been told
that they've all ran off to get dinner
or prepare for their next game so yeah
unfortunately we won't have any more
interviews we also had a board 10 which
we never got to
yeah I think we didn't this end game
finished
um by the way here
um
so quesada Perez Yasser was able to push
he did win yeah why don't we go back
because this was also an interesting end
game if we go back to
just where we left it off because the
engine was saying this was zero zero
zero but I I was going to say this is
another one of those end games it's
really hard to play for white because
black has that outside pass Pawn over
there and you can't get your king over
there because the the Knight and Rook
cut the white king off and that white
Pawn on F2 is weak
so from a practical perspective you know
the Knight on C5 looks very nice but you
got to do something about you know A6 to
A1 and even though that's five moves
it's very very hard to figure out how to
organize your pieces here as white
yes she she ended up playing Knight C5
which allowed the push and then she's
right here but this these two pieces are
not connected into doing much it's just
a check and then punished interestingly
look in the computer it calls Knight C5
a blunder and it takes the position from
minus Point 0.1 or 0.01 to -1.5 so it's
it's fully a pawn and a half blunder to
play Knight C5 which is the most obvious
move yeah
and that's why this is so tough I
suggestion apparently but I don't know
if that's
I don't know
if that's to play 95
because that was my first my first
thought to go 95 and try to trade but
probably
in that situation we will stay with this
super weak Pawn so the point is probably
to go F4 and then I'm thinking depending
on what he does let's say he goes you
know he follows his plan right we can
give this check I think
and then this is what I'm thinking for
white
um
you go here do we have time well can you
just bring the king over now can we
do we have 101 A3 we're here King C1
not sure where we moved the Rook
oh yeah if I go to B3 you go
if you go there
you go here right yeah rugby
no rugby to wear back right back and
then here
well actually we don't even need this
move we can just come here and and
weight is doing yeah yeah
we cannot do that right but I mean one
of the lessons I've learned in life is
if you can get your king over Inside the
Box do it in these positions because
then your your risk goes down so
well also of course the king should be
brought towards the center
um that's for sure but or towards the
the past bonds but with the Knights it's
much more difficult so certainly this
was an idea it was important to see not
Knight C5 but Knight E5 tried to trade
the Knight and then if the night would
go then D5 and and things but I think
um I think we should wrap it up for
today
um it was great to have all of you guys
here it was wonderful doing commentary
with you Doug I hope you enjoyed it too
I did it was fun and there were some
interesting games today and I hope
everyone enjoyed the fact that this was
good Fighting Chess and we saw some you
know lower rated players score some
draws against some extraordinarily
strong players so congratulations to
Irina
and Evan yes I think that was it that
was it everyone else the top uh top
the person who is supposed to win on
paper ended up winning
um it's definitely a tough tournament
and I think in the next round we're
gonna see lots of Grandmasters playing
against each other unfortunately we
won't be doing commentary for that round
but in the next round tomorrow morning
at 11 20 11 30
a.m Central Time 11 20. that's what I
was told we hope to see you there on
Street well here on stream will
um
meet again
documentary for round three of the San
Luis super Swiss thank you for being
with us and have a wonderful rest of
your day yes we'll see you tomorrow
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited